Der sechste Spieltag der 2. Bundesliga der Männer ist ausgespielt und wir wollen über die Gewinner und Verlierer des Saisonstarts reden. Was macht Tabellenführer Darmstadt? Daran muss man sich ein bisschen gewöhnen. So gut explodiert Schalke unter Muzlic und was ist jetzt eigentlich schon wieder bei Hertha BSC los? Darüber spreche ich in dieser 2. Liga Sendung mit Kevin Bublitz vom PadaCast und Matthias Kneifl vom Hohen Weit Podcast. Let's go!
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rossi zu kurz Abwehr, lang genug für Gilly Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1-0. Markus Kurt aus dem Bivou.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Hach, ich hab das Intro vermisst. Und ich, das ist Marc Schwitzki an der Stelle. Ich führe heute wieder durch diese– was heißt wieder? endlich wieder durch diese Zweitligasendung des Rasenfunk. Ich bin freier Journalist. Ihr lest mich meistens beim RBB und hört mich bei Hertha Bays. Und nachdem Eva dankenswerterweise die letzten zwei Folgen gemacht hatte dieser schönen Zweitigasendung und ich zwischenzeitlich im Urlaub war, bin ich wieder da und top motiviert bis in die Haarspitzen. Aber nicht nur ich, zum anderen ist auch dabei Pada Born-Fan, Host des PadaCast und selbsternannter Prophet Kevin Bublitz. Ich grüße dich.
Hi, danke für diese tolle Vorstellung.
Ich wusste es. Hey, du hast das ganze Wochenende darauf rumgeritten. Jetzt muss ich es auch mit reinnehmen. Gast Nr. 2 ist Anhänger der Darmstädter Lilien, Host des Hoch- und Weitpodcasts und heute eher der Mann für die milden Töne. Sag ich jetzt einfach mal, Matthias Kneifl, ich grüße dich.
Ja, servus, hallo zusammen. Freut mich, hier mitzuwirken und mitzumischen. Und bin gut gelaunt. Wer hätte es gedacht?
Ja, bist du sicherlich bei deinem Debüt jetzt im Rasenfunk-Zweitliga-All-Star-Team. Wir müssen uns dafür immer noch einen griffigeren Namen überlegen. Aber Rasenfunk-Avengers wurde schon vorgeschlagen, finde ich gar nicht so schlecht. Aber vielleicht tun wir da den Leuten in der ersten Liga auch ein bisschen unrecht. Who knows, ist aber auch egal. Was nicht egal ist, dieser Podcast ist, sprecht mir nach, werbe-, Paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich allein durch die Spenden der HörerInnen, beispielsweise dieses Mal genannt Rasmus, Andreas P und Valdini, bei denen wir uns allesamt bedanken wollen. Die Spenden finanzieren nicht nur den Lebensunterhalt von Max, sondern ermöglichen auch, dass sowohl die Gäste ein Honorar bekommen, als auch Menschen wie ich und Eva, die den Podcast ja ebenfalls moderieren können. Wenn ihr das unterstützen wollt, dann schaut doch mal vorbei auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Die Spenden ermöglichen auch, dass diese Woche wieder eine pickepackevolle Rasenfunkwoche wird. Lasst es mich einmal euch vortragen. Tragt es euch in eure Kalender ein. Also natürlich gibt es wieder die Spieltagsbesprechung der Bundesliga der Männer in der Nacht auf den Montag. Die Bundesliga der Frauen wird am Montagabend besprochen. Es gibt einen Fokus auf Bayer Leverkusen nach dem großen Trainer-Drama am Dienstagabend. Dann gibt es noch eine Besprechung am Donnerstagabend zur Bundesliga der Frauen und in der Nacht auf den Montag gibt es dann auch den nächsten Bundesligaspieltag der Männer, moderiert von Caro Kippe. Da freue ich mich auch drauf. So, das war jetzt sehr viel Hausmitteilung, sehr viel Vorstellung. Wir werden ab jetzt sportlich, wie gesagt, der 6. Spieltag der 2. Bundesliga der Männer ist gespielt. Und das lädt so ein Stück weit dazu ein, mal so ein wenig über die Gewinner und Verlierer des Saisons stattzureden. Das kann man sicherlich noch mal nach dem 10. Spieltag machen und das so ein bisschen ausweiten, aber ich glaube schon, dass wir jetzt nach so fünf, sechs Spieltagen Tendenzen erkennen. Und da dieses Format ja alle zwei Wochen rauskommt, lohnt es sich, glaube ich, jetzt vielleicht mal diesen kleinen Zwischencut zu machen und zu schauen, wer fällt denn besonders positiv und wer fällt besonders negativ auf und woran liegt das eigentlich so genau? Deswegen haben wir alle so ein bisschen diesen Spieltag natürlich besonders im Fokus gehabt, aber auch in die letzten Wochen geguckt und geschaut, wie sieht es denn bei den Teams aus? Und ich dachte mir, ich beginne jetzt einfach mal und rede über meinen ersten Gewinner dieses Saisonstarts in der 2. Liga. Und es ist kein überraschender Name, aber es muss darüber gesprochen werden. Beziehungsweise es ist ein überraschender Name, weil das nicht viele erwartet haben, aber es ist nicht überraschend, dass sie jetzt in dieser Sendung gelandet sind. Die SV Elversberg. Die SV Elversberg grüßt nicht ganz von der Tabellenspitze, aber ist punktgleich mit Darmstadt 98, über die wir sicherlich auch noch reden werden. Und wer hätte das gedacht? Also viele Saisonprognosen sind meiner. Wir hätten derzeit frustriert in den Mülleimer geworfen. Die SV Elversberg weigert sich, jetzt einzubrechen und belehrt uns mal wieder eines Besseren und marschiert auch ohne Haus Steffen, Fisnik Aslani, Mohamed Damar, Shahin oder auch Baum weiter durch die Liga. Vincent Wagner führt dieses Projekt erstklassig fort. 13 Punkte nach 6 Spielen, erst eine Niederlage und seit 4 Spielen ist man ungeschlagen. Und jetzt am 6. Spieltag gab es ein überzeugendes 4 zu 1 in Braunstein. Ja, man hat auch von der Überzahl profitiert ab der 63. Minute, hat dann noch 2 Tore geschossen, bis dann stand das nur 2 zu 1. Aber es war ein insgesamt wieder überzeugendes Spiel. Und mit Yunus Abnou Talib, dem möchte ich auf jeden Fall erwähnen, dem 22-jährigen Mittelstürmer, formt sich gerade auch schon wieder dieser nächste Star, in Anführungsstrichen, in Elversberg, 6 Tore in 6 Spielen, wobei er die alle in den letzten 3 Spielen erzielt hat. Also es läuft schon wieder da im Saarland. Matthias, kannst du dir das erklären, wie das zustande kommt, obwohl man so einen Adalas im Sommer hatte?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich faszinierend, muss ich auch sagen. Ich hatte sie nicht jetzt Vorsaisonbeginn so eingeschätzt, dass sie quasi von hinten die Tabelle ziehen würden, sondern ich hatte doch ihnen zugetraut, dass es eine Saison wird, in der sie sich behaupten können. Und wer weiß, du hast jetzt schon angeführt, wer denn alles tatsächlich den Verein verlassen hat. Womöglich war das sogar ein Gutes, weil die Erwartungshaltung war deshalb gar nicht mehr da, dass man vorne jetzt sozusagen den nächsten Schritt macht. Man endet ja als Tabellen-Dritter und oft ist es ja so, dass dann in der breiten Wahrnehmung gesagt wird, na jetzt müssen sie den nächsten Schritt machen, also sind sie automatisch Aufstiegsanwärter oder ein Spitzenteam. Und diese Diskussion hat sich ja sofort erledigt durch diesen Adelhass und vor allem auch durch den Verlust des Trainers, der ja erst recht so als der Mastermind hinter dem ganzen Projekt, wenn ich es jetzt mal despektierlich gesehen wurde. Also sprich, man hat gefühlt so ein bisschen bei Null begonnen, wobei das auch nicht ganz stimmt. Also man hat immer noch natürlich Nils-Ole Bog, ich glaube der Name muss fallen, als der sportlich Verantwortliche im Hintergrund behalten, der sicherlich auch mit dazu beigetragen hat, dass Elbersberg die letzten 7, 8 Jahre das geworden ist, was es geworden ist und im Moment darstellt. Also sprich, die Personalie ist geblieben und sicherlich nicht zu unterschätzen. Und dann hat man es eben auch geschafft, weiterhin alte Kempten an Bord zu halten. Also da gibt es ja durchaus auch, jetzt habe ich kurz mal einen Spicker in meine Dokumente und kann es schon gar nicht mehr sehen. Aber auf jeden Fall, man hat ja durchaus auch noch ein paar Leute, die schon in der Viertel Liga gestartet sind und immer noch dabei sind. Das heißt, die wissen eigentlich, was Elbersberg ausmacht. Und um nochmal an meinen ursprünglichen Gedanken anzuknüpfen, ich glaube, dass jetzt so ein Wandel war in der breiten Wahrnehmung, was die Personalien anbetrifft, konnte dem Ganzen vielleicht auch zum Vorteil gereichen. Also die Erwartungshaltung war gleich Null. Sie haben auch ein ruhiges Umfeld. Also sprich, da ist keine Erwartungshaltung, wie wenn man jetzt in die Region guckt, was da benachbarten ist, Saarbrücken oder auch der Waldhof, wenn man es ein bisschen weiter spannt, den Radius. Das sind halt Traditionsteams. Da ist die Erwartungshaltung im Umfeld immer gleich groß. Also hier wurde was angezündet, hier geht es jetzt weiter, zwangsläufig. Und Elbersberg, ich stelle jetzt einfach so einen Standort ein, der ist sehr ruhig, der ist professionell aufgestellt, mit dem quasi Herrn im Hintergrund, sprich dem Frank Holzer als Geldgeber nenne ich es jetzt mal, der das ganze Projekt auch seit 30 Jahren oder 35 Jahren begleitet. Das ist sehr gesettelt. Also da gibt es in Baden-Württemberg zum Beispiel, natürlich Hoffenheim kennen wir alle, aber auch Groß Asbach, das sind so Teams, die sind Dorfteams, die sind von unten hochgekommen, die sind aber mit einem klaren Plan hochgekommen, die haben Leute an den richtigen Stellen, die ihr Handwerk verstehen und die deshalb einen Verein auch in einem ruhigeren Fahrwasser, aber kontinuierlich weiterentwickeln und das setzt sich jetzt dieses Jahr erstaunlicherweise fort und deshalb bin ich da schwer angetan von dem, was sie wieder leisten, weil es auch fußballerisch einfach ansprechend ist und deshalb würde ich an der Stelle erstmal den Ablinder machen. Also überraschend ja, aber vielleicht erklärbar durch die Komponenten, die ich jetzt gerade schon gesagt hatte, die immer noch da sind, aber nicht so visibel wie die Leute, die auf dem Platz rumrennen. Und ich denke, wenn man sich erinnert, wer in den letzten Jahren so die Shootingstars waren, die von großen Vereinen geliehen wurden, Voltemade, Wanner, Aslani oder auch Baum, dann ist für mich jetzt fast schon Otto Stange, so derjenige, der in dieses Raster reinpasst, weil den Goalgetter hat man gerade schon erwähnt, ja, mit sechs Treffern. Aber Otto Stange ist bei einem großen Verein, ist ein aufstrebendes Talent, hat jetzt in der 2. Liga, glaube ich, das passende Umfeld, um sich weiterzuentwickeln und hat es jetzt gestern schon angedeutet. Also der Otto Stange ist für mich so ein bisschen derjenige, der in die Fußstapfen der anderen tritt, weil er einfach so ein bisschen das Raster des in einem ruhigen Umfeld gedeihen und sich interessant machen noch besser erfüllt.
Absolut. 18 Jahre jung, schon zwei Vorlagen auf dem Konto. Also da bahnt sich was an. Man hat ja mit Bambassee Conté letztes Jahr in den KSC verliehen, ein Talent von Hofmein geliehen. Du hast Malanga vom VfB geliehen, Poreva von HSV. Das passt jetzt nicht total in diese Talenteriege, aber zumindest auch wieder ein Spieler von einem eigentlich größeren Verein, der sich dort wieder festigen will. Also du hast es schon sehr, sehr gut erklärt. Es fußt alles auf einem wahnsinnig stabilen Fundament. Und das war dann wahrscheinlich auch der Grund dafür, warum sich Vincent Wagner so schnell akklimatisieren konnte und seine Idee da umsetzen konnte. Kevin, was macht denn Wagner für einen Eindruck auf dich und dementsprechend auch der Fußball, den er spielen lässt?
Ich habe schon so viel dazu gesagt eigentlich. Matthias vor allem mir hat es auch gerade ganz treffend. Für mich hat sich, um die Brücke zu schlagen, vor der Sorge die Frage gestellt, werden die ihr Konzept jetzt über den Haufen werfen? Also sprich, ist das mit dem Coach gegangen? Oder ist es dann doch vielmehr das Konzept von Bug oder halt vom Klub selbst? Und man holt dazu den passenden Trainer. Da erkenne ich eine gewisse Parallele zu dem Verein, den ich gerne schaue. Das ist ein Mist, der war da born. Ja, dass du halt als Verein dabei bleibst. Du hast eine eigene Philosophie in der Spielidee. Und natürlich ist der Trainer wichtig. Und bringt auch jetzt der neue Coach seine Elemente mit rein. Aber ich finde, Elversberg spielt weiter in diesem sehr attraktiven, auch teilweise Überfallfußball, der sich stark macht. Ich glaube, diese Komponente, dass man sie nicht so ganz ausrechnen konnte, ist tatsächlich sehr wichtig. Es ist immer für solche Vereine wichtig, dass sie irgendwie als Underdog gelten. Ja, eigentlich müssen die doch unten vielleicht drinstehen oder zumindest maximal im Mittelfeld dieses Jahr. Die Besten sind ja alle weg. Aber man setzt dieses Konzept gut fort, hat einen Coach geholt. Ich nenne ihn jetzt mal unbeschriebenes Blatt irgendwo. Auch ein gutes Konzept passt zu jungen Spielern sehr gut, finde ich. Und aber auch wichtig, dass er noch die, wie hast du sie genannt, Matthias Alten-Recken, Klemmen, genau. Ja, dass er die noch dabei hat, weil die natürlich auch die Liga kennen, die die Erfahrung im Team haben und ganz wichtiger Aspekt einfach auch den Verein gelebt haben bisher schon und wissen, worauf es dort ankommt.
Absolut Namen wie Nikolas Christoph im Tor, Schnellbacher im Sturm, Zimmerschied, die sind ja alle geblieben, ja.
Ja, und auch Lucas Pinkert wird jetzt der Kapitän, also auch das gehört dazu. Und sie haben tatsächlich jetzt nicht nur junge Leute geholt, sondern sie haben auch mit Kondé, ein Spieler, der die 2. Liga kennt, noch mal aus Jamra dazu geholt, Jamra, genau. Also das heißt, sie haben ein paar erfahrende Spiele dazu geholt, sind ansonsten ihrem Jugendstil, nenne ich jetzt mal im Großen und Ganzen treu geblieben. Und da passt natürlich so ein Coach dazu wie Vincent Wagner, der mit Hoffenheim 2 ja auch sehr überzeugend in die 3. Liga aufgestiegen ist. Also der sicherlich auch in Elbersberg bekannt war. Die Wege nach Hoffenheim sind jetzt auch nicht so weit. Man hatte Leihspieler von Hoffenheim gleichwohl aus dem Profi-Team und nicht aus der Zweitvertretung. Aber ich denke, da war gut gescoutet und ein Trainer, der einfach da in das System, dass man spielen will, passt. Und ich hatte jetzt in Vorbereitung auf die Sendung auch nochmal ein Interview mit dem Frank Holzer nachgelesen, das Ende letzten Jahres im Kicker erschienen ist. Also da ist ganz klar rauszulesen, wir wollen hier in der zweiten Liga am Ball bleiben. Die wollen jetzt nicht irgendwie, klar ist der Umbruch im Sommer nicht absehbar gewesen damals, aber die wollen nicht sagen, ja, dann war es das halt alles so schön bunt hier, jetzt geht es wieder runter. Nein, ich glaube, da ist ganz klar die Absicht, dran zu bleiben. Und wenn sich mal das Tor nach oben öffnen sollte, größer vielleicht noch als jetzt im Sommer, dann gehen die da auch durch. Also so zumindest das Selbstverständnis, wie es aus dem Interview herauskommt und ich bin gespannt.
Das Ganze ist ganz witzig, vielleicht noch eine kleine Anekdote. Vincent Wagner hatte man als Bekannter des Lukas Quassenjog nicht beim SC Paderborn bleibt, tatsächlich auch mal im Trainingsnachwuchsleistungszentrum in Paderborn gesichtet. Ich weiß nicht, was er da getan hat. Da hätte man noch nicht offiziell bekannt gegeben. Also ein super spannender, junger nachwuchsnachrückender Trainer, was auch wirklich inzwischen auch ein Kompliment für die zweite Liga einfach ist, dass viele neue Trainer auch eine Chance bekommen.
Absolut, das zieht sich durch die letzten Jahre. Vincent Wagner, um hier einmal Boulevardesse auch alle abzuholen, hat ja auch schon einen radikalen Style-Change hinter sich. Er kam mit den langen Haaren, sagte, er lässt sie wachsen, bis er, glaube ich, das erste Mal mit Elbersberg gewinnt. War das die Prämisse? Ich glaube schon. Das hat sich sehr schnell erledigt. Tatsächlich. Das war, jetzt muss er sich irgendwas Neues ausdenken. Irgendwie höhere Ziele aussuchen, weil sonst folgt die nächste Frisur auch sehr schnell. Aber vielleicht wird das ja auch einfach ein Ding. Elbersberg bleibt sich unter ihm taktisch wirklich treu. Man hat den höchsten Ballbesitz der Liga, die drittbeste Passquote, spielt kaum bis keine Flanken. Also alles sehr flach angelegt. Und trotzdem ist es läuferisch irreintensiv. Das zieht sich auch jetzt durch die Trainer, dass das eben nicht nur eine Schönspielerei ist, sondern dass das immer gepaart ist mit immens vielen Tiefenläufen und auch der nötigen Arbeit in der 2. Liga gegen den Ball. Und das zeigt eben auch, dass du da anscheinend immer wieder auch, da ist dein Bog sehr zu loben, die richtigen Charaktere in die Mannschaft holst, die sich diesem Spielstil unterordnen. Klar, die irgendwas Eigenes reinbringen. Man hat ja bei Damar oder Aslani auch gesehen, dass das starke Individualisten sind, aber eben in einem gewissen Korsett. Und das funktioniert mit dem Fundament, mit der Ruhe, die ihr eben beschrieben habt in diesem Umfeld, glaube ich, sehr gut. Und sorgt dafür, dass Elvesberg überraschend für mich– ich hätte es eben nicht so gedacht, aber wurde jetzt eines Besseren belehrt– genauso weiter ruhig durch diese Liga cruist. Und ob das dann am Ende für den großen Wurf reicht, das wird man mal sehen. Aber allein, dass sie jetzt schon so gut gestartet sind, wird auch da wieder ohnehin schon zur großen Ruhe beitragen und jungen Spieler eher reifen lassen, als wenn sie jetzt direkt irgendwie durch das Stahlbad müssten. Matthias, ich habe jetzt über einen Gewinner geredet. Wollen wir jetzt schon direkt zu deinem Verein kommen? Was meinst du?
Können wir gerne machen, klar. Darmstadt 98 grüßt von der Tabellenspitze. Kann natürlich nächste Woche auch schon wieder Platz 7 sein. Die Liga ist einfach sehr eng, aber dennoch der Saisonstart ist geglückt. Ich glaube, das kann man mit Fug und Recht behaupten. Sechs Spiele, vier Siege, ein Unentschieden, eine Niederlage, Pokal weitergekommen. Jetzt nicht im Hurra-Fußball damals in Lübeck, aber nichtsdestotrotz sind sie weitergekommen. Und wenn man sich die Spiele so ein bisschen anguckt, dann waren da zwei überzeugende Siege dabei. Zum einen heute in Düsseldorf, aber auch am ersten Saisonspiel gegen Bochum. Dann waren zwei Siege dabei, die waren so ein bisschen spitze auf Knopf. Also wir haben in letzter Minute in Nürnberg gewonnen. Das war Anfang des Jahres genau umgekehrt ein ereignisarmes Spiel, das Nürnberg zum Schluss gezogen hat. Dieses Mal war es andersrum. Und dann hatte man auch gegen Braunschweig noch verstanden, zum Schluss den Sieg einzufahren. Dann ein Remy gegen die Hatter, da was du dich womöglich daran erinnern mag. Das hätte in beide Richtungen kippen können. Und gegen Kaiserslautern hat man 84 Minuten das Spiel im Griff gehabt, zeige ich mal. Und dann macht Kaiserslautern, Kaiserslautern Dinge. Und ist seitdem auf dem aufsteigenden Ast. Und wir haben da leider 1 zu 3 verloren. Hier heißt die Ligien. Aber was ganz entscheidend ist, sind diese engen Spiele. Also das 1 zu 0 Nürnberg oder auch das 2 zu 1 gegen Braunschweig. Solche Spiele hätte man in der letzten Saison womöglich nicht gewonnen und womöglich sogar verloren. Und ich habe die Gelegenheit mit Spielern oder auch mal mit dem Manager, Paul Fearny, zu sprechen für das Stadion-Magazin. Das war jetzt so im letzten Monaten der Fall. Und es zieht sich wie ein roter Faden durch die Gespräche. Auch Marcel Schuhn ist jetzt wieder Kapitän oder ist Kapitän. War ein bisschen Vertreter für Fabi Holland, aber im letzten Jahr war es eben Clemens Riedeln. Jetzt ist es de facto Marcel Schuhn. Und er oder auch Fearny sagen unisono und auch Alexander Bukotic, die Mannschaft muss lernen, Spiele zu gewinnen. Also dieser Lernprozess, das ist das Wichtige. Und die Mannschaft scheint es für den Moment verstanden zu haben, worauf es ankommt. Weil letztes Jahr, wir erinnern uns, da waren ein paar Horasiege dabei. Sie sind überzeugend, 5 zu 1 gegen Karlslautern und auch gegen Köln überzeugend gewonnen, gegen Karlsruhe überzeugend gewonnen. Schalke, nenne ich mich. Schalke, das waren dann aber einfach so Spiele, die irgendwie Selbstläufer waren irgendwann. Aber diese mühseligen Siege, sage ich mal, auch diese dreckigen Siege, die haben sie lange Zeit gar nicht verstanden zu ziehen. Erst so mit einem 1 zu 0 gegen Viertel in der Rückrunde. Und das Bewusstsein, das sagen wir eben, diese Gespräche ist da, dass die Mannschaft lernen muss, solche Spiele zu ziehen. Und zwar, schon spielen kann irgendwann mal jeder, sich so ein bisschen in den Lauf rein zu manövrieren innerhalb eines Spiels, aber hart dran zu arbeiten, dass der Siege auch auf seine Seite fällt. Darauf kommt es an.
Und da kriege ich mal kurz rein, weil ich das Gefühl habe, ist das nicht vielleicht sogar ein Lernprozess, den Florian Kohfeldt selbst irgendwo tätigen musste, weil ich ihn als Trainer bislang auch so wahrgenommen hatte, auch wenn wir seine Bremenzeit zum Beispiel nehmen, wenn alles im Flow ist und so. Dann fallen die Dinge leicht, aber diese mühseligen Siege, deswegen lief die Zeit im Wolfsburg vielleicht auch nicht so einfach für ihn. Da hat er sich ja auch selbst sehr schwergetan, hatte ich immer das Gefühl als Trainer. Und die letzte Rückrunde, wo du das angesprochen hast, war ja auch noch unter diesen Zeichen.
Ja, wobei er schon in der Winterpause oder schon im Verlauf der Hinrunde, wir erinnern uns, er kam zum fünften Spieltag der letzten Saison, dann gab es diese Kohfeldtabelle sehr lange Zeit, weil sie einfach die Liga in der Tabelle angeführt haben. Also sie starteten ja mit einem Punkt aus drei oder vier Spielen und dann gab es die Kohfeldtabelle. Man rollte so ein bisschen das Feld von hinten auf, auch wenn es nie höher als Rang 10 ging. Aber da sagte er auch schon, ihm ist das ein bisschen too much. Also jetzt wird alles positiv gesehen, aber es ist nicht positiv. Es ist weder schwarz noch weiß. Es kommt auf die Krauthöne an und hat da sofort so ein bisschen versucht, die Bremse reinzuhauen, weil ihm, glaube ich, das Ganze ein bisschen aus seiner Erfahrung heraus zu ungeheuerlich wurde. Und die Rückrunde, die gestaltete sich dann eben als sehr zäh. Also man hat wichtige Spieler gehabt, die nicht spielen konnten aufgrund von Verletzungen. Liedberg, man muss sicherlich auch nochmal erwähnen, war da einer davon, aber auch ein Kai Klefisch, der so nicht überall mehr haben muss, aber schon auch als emotionaler Spieler nicht ganz unwichtig ist in dem Konstrukt. Und deshalb war auch damals schon in der Rückrunde Kohfeldt mit der Aussage am Start, wir müssen in allen Mannschaftsteilen Verantwortung tragen. Das bedeutet, die Defensive muss stabil stehen und die Offensive darf sich aber auch nicht zu viele Chancenbrüche erlauben. Also das war auch ein klarer Appell an die Stürmer, die ja durchaus auch auf sich aufmerksam machen konnten, dennoch ihre Chancen seriös zu nutzen und zu wissen, sie haben eine Verantwortung für die gesamte Mannschaft, wenn sie eine Chance haben. Also das mag vielleicht ein bisschen Druck erzeugen klingen, aber ich glaube, das sollte daran appellieren, dass keiner irgendwie so glaubt, das ist alles ein Selbstläufer, sondern die Sinne wurden geschärft, das war schon letztes Jahr in der Rückrunde so, hat nicht durchweg gefruchtet, aber vielleicht ist das jetzt so ein bisschen eine Erklärung, dass manchmal jetzt diese engen Spiele eben auch gezogen wurden, weil die Mannschaft vielleicht immer mehr verinnerlicht, es geht nicht darum, schön zu spielen oder überwiegend überzeugend zu spielen, sondern es geht darum, zu gewinnen. Punkt. Und im Moment bin ich in deren Sicht schon mal zufrieden, dass eine gewisse Entwicklung zu sehen ist. Mal gucken, wie es sich weiterentwickelt.
Richtig. Aber ich hatte, wie gesagt, das Spiel gegen Hertha erwähnt, dementsprechend habe ich sie zumindest einmal bei 90 Minuten gesehen und mehrmals jetzt schon in einer Konferenz oder ähnliches. Und ich finde, dass Darmstadt bislang wirklich eine große Stabilität und vielleicht auch eine neu gewonnene Balance. Vielleicht ist das ja auch ein Teil des Reife-Prozesses. Also es ist nicht nur schön Spiele rein, nur wir laufen nach vorne, sondern ich finde, Darmstadt ist defensiv superschwer zu knacken. Das liegt natürlich auch ein Stück weit an den Funktürmen, die man da hinten drin stehen hat. Also es ist teilweise auch individuelle Klasse, ob es ein Vukovic, das ein Maglizar ist. Aber es ist auch die genaue Gesamtkennung.
Patrick Pfeiffer nicht zu vergessen.
Patrick Pfeiffer natürlich, klar. Aber auch wie sich da alle in den Dienst der Mannschaft stellen, da nehme ich zum Beispiel Papella, der ja eigentlich kein Rechtsverteidiger ist, dort aber ausgeholfen hat und auch ich, wie ich finde, einen guten Job gemacht hat. Das ist immer ein Indiz dafür, dass das Gesamtgebilde stimmt. Wenn sich Spieler dann in neuen Situationen, auf neuen Rollen relativ schnell einfühlen, dann ist das natürlich ein Teil, auch individueller Klasse spricht, aber auch für das Gesamtkonstrukt, was diese Mannschaft bildet. Und so habe ich das Gefühl, dass Darmstadt unter Kohfeldt mittlerweile ein sehr, sehr, sehr stabiles Gebilde ist, mit sogar dem Potenzial mehr als das zu sein in gewissen Momenten, in gewissen Spielen, so wie es dann heute vielleicht gegen Düsseldorf der Fall war, wo man dann irgendwann– klar, da gehört auch ein Gegner dazu, der das erlaubt– aber wo du diese Mannschaft irgendwann auch einfach überrollt hast mit deiner individuellen Klasse und der Wucht, die du vorne erzeugen kannst, mit individuellen Spielern wie Hornby, Liedberg, Marco Richter. Also solide bis sehr gut. Da ist irgendwie alles drin, habe ich gerade das Gefühl.
Ja, das ist durchaus zu verspüren, wenn man mit den Leuten spricht. Also auch ein Fraser Hornby, der in Belgien schon gespielt hat, in Frankreich, in Schottland, in England, der noch relativ jung war, als zu Ligien kam. Es gibt viele Spieler, mit denen ich rede, die sagen, sie fühlen sich hier pudelwohl. Also die Mannschaft stimmt, die sind sich grün. Da gibt es vielleicht, also ich mag schon glauben, dass sich nicht jeder Friede vor der Eierkuchen ist, aber die betonen unisono, wie wohl sie sich in Darmstadt fühlen. Also die Mannschaft ist sich in deren Sicht wohlgesonnen. Die empfinden sich, glaube ich, wirklich als eine verschworene Truppe. Und das kann schon mal sehr helfen an der Stelle. Auch ausfälle kurzfristig auf einer fremden Position, wie du gerade mit Papella als Rechtsverteidiger erwähnt hast, aufzufüllen und die Position dann auch auszufüllen. Und was sicherlich auch noch mit dazu gehört, die Basis war einfach da in diesem Jahr. Also letztes Jahr nach dem Bundesliga-Abstieg hatte man sehr viel tabula rasa im Kader. Gleichwohl schon hochwertige Spieler gewonnen, da möchte ich auch Korridoren nennen, der sicherlich auch seinen Teil zum Erfolg beiträgt. Und dann hatte man dieses Jahr nicht mehr die Notwendigkeit, noch mal einen Umbruch zu vollziehen, sondern man war auf der Suche nach den richtigen Stücken, die noch fehlten. Und da ist jemand wie Patrick Pfeiffer jemand, der einfach von hinten Flugbälle spielt, die einfach gefährlich sind. Also wir haben es jetzt heute bei dem zweiten Tor in Düsseldorf gesehen, das war mit verschuldet auch durch den Düsseldorfer Verteidiger, der dann nicht lernen konnte. Aber das war ein langer Diagonalball und sowas gab es auch schon diverse Male in Kaislautern zum Beispiel, als das 1-0 durchliegt, gleich dann fiel. Also das ist ein Element, das kam dazu. Er hat eine gewisse Schnelligkeit, Kopfballstärke und der blüht jetzt hier wieder ein bisschen auf, das, was er bei den anderen Stationen zwischenzeitlich nicht hatte. Und wen ich auch noch erwähnen mag, ist Akiyama, der heute sein Premiärentor geschossen hat. Ein Spieler, der aus Japan direkt verpflichtet wurde, der keine Zwischenstation irgendwo in Europa hatte, was inzwischen für viele Japaner ja durchaus selbstverständlich ist. Und er spricht nicht die Sprache, aber er wurde behutsam aufgebaut. Er bekam immer mehr Spielzeiten, 45 Minuten, 60 Minuten, 75 Minuten. Jetzt hat er zweimal durchgespielt und er hat ein wahnsinnig gutes Spielverständnis. Ich konnte auch mich nach seiner Verpflichtung mal mit einem Sportjournalisten aus Japan austauschen über ihn. Der meinte, Passspiel, überall mehr haben, sehr gute Stats, Lauf stark, aber im Defensivverhalten Luft nach oben. Da war ich erstmal so ein bisschen gespannt und im Moment im Verbund mit Kleffisch fällt es nicht so stark ins Gewicht, aber er gibt dem Team durch seine Passsicherheit auch eine gewisse Ruhe. Und die tut dem Ganzen gut, deshalb bin ich sehr gespannt, wie er sich weiter akklimatisieren kann hier an der Stelle in der 2. Liga. Also insofern, man hatte keine Notwendigkeit eines Umbruchs, es war viel da, man ist dabei in der Achse herauszuarbeiten, herauszubilden und insofern wenig Grund zur Klage.
Kevin von außen, wie beurteilst du denn die Entwicklung von Damenstand unter Kohfeldt und was glaubst du ist dann in dieser so engen Liga für die Ligien letztendlich auch drin?
Ja, obwohl auf jeden Fall deutlich mehr als ich gedacht hätte vor der Saison. Liegt aber daran, dass ich einfach Darmstadt nicht so intensiv verfolge. Letztes Jahr war eine Konsolidierungs-Saison ganz klar, haben viele Mannschaften, die nicht das Riesen-Buget haben, wobei auch Mannschaften die das Riesen-Buget haben, die außer ersten Liga absteigen, müssen sich ein paar Jahre manchmal sammeln. Es ist einfach dem geschult, dass die 2. Liga unfassbar eng beieinander ist, so hast du ja glaube ich gesagt, Matthias, am Anfang. Ihr könnt im nächsten Spiel auch schon wieder was, was ich wo stehen. Genau. Was ich von außen beobachte, ist, dass ihr es halt richtig gut gemacht habt, dass ihr den Kader dann nicht wieder durcheinander gewirbelt habt, sondern wirklich klug geschaut habt, auf welchen Positionen fehlt uns noch was, wo müssen wir noch doppelt besetzen, wer bringt uns wirklich weiter. Klefisch, den ich ja auch noch kenne, super Abräumer, war bei uns immer ein vogelwilder Typ, aber ein sehr emotionaler Typ, der auch ein Team mal mitpushen kann. Freut mich sehr, dass er sich dann auch bei euch etabliert hat. Du hast den goldenen Satz gesagt, das Klima stimmt, die Stimmung ist super. Da können wir uns umdrehen, wie wir wollen. Da kannst du Top-Spieler holen, wie du willst. Wenn es da nicht passt, dann kannst du es knicken. Dann stehst du halt irgendwo unten oder im Mittelfeld. Aber wenn das passt, so wie bei euch, dann ist das einfach immer so ein Ding. Dann gewinnst du und dann ziehst du diese Spiele, die knapp sind, die du im letzten Jahr nicht geholt hast, wo du noch ein bisschen brauchst. Auch stark vom Verein, dann so einem Trainer, auch die Zeit zu geben. Ich finde, Kohlfeldt hat ja auch sehr viel einstecken müssen in den letzten Jahren. Hätte ich nicht erwartet, dass er so viel Kredit bekommt, dass er so lange Zeit bekommt, die Mannschaft auch zu entwickeln, mag ich sehr gerne und macht Darmstadt für mich wieder ein Stück noch sympathischer. Ich bin gespannt, was diese Saison geht. Du hast natürlich Glück, dass Liedberg auch einfach einen Top-Lauf hat. Dass er geblieben ist und dass er einfach auch diesen Lauf jetzt hat. Dann müssen jetzt halt du nichts für sorgen, dass der irgendwie jede Woche in diesen Zaubertrank fällt, da aus dem Gallischen Dorf und weiter so netzt. Dann kannst du natürlich richtig Punkte sammeln, mit denen du vielleicht auch gar nicht so gerechnet hast.
Ja, völlig. Du hattest jetzt Liedberg auch bei dem Spiel gegen Kaiserslautern oder bei dem Spiel gegen Braunschweig lange Zeit gar nicht gesehen. Er hatte nicht viele Anteile am Spiel, aber er hat zweimal getroffen. Das zeigt auch, dass er nicht so viele Chancen braucht, womöglich. Er hat trotzdem viel läuft. Also die Mannschaft mag vielleicht in den Laufstatistiken nicht ganz weit vorne liegen. Das kann ich jetzt gar nicht sagen, aber sie ist auf jeden Fall dennoch bereit, Wege zu gehen. Und da gehört auch so jemand wie Horn wieder zu, der zweite Spitze spielt oder auch hängende Spitze, der auch viele Wege geht, der auch, obwohl er vielleicht auf den ersten Blick gar nicht so erscheinen mag, aber sehr gutes Spielverständnis, sehr guten Überblick hat, der auch ursprünglich, als ich mit ihm gesprochen hatte, hat er gesagt, er ist als schottischer Nationalspieler, hat er auf der 6. gespielt und im Verein bei Everton in der U19 war er Stürmer. Das heißt, er weiß im Endeffekt, was die Mittelfeldspieler von ihm wollen. Also er weiß deshalb auch, die Wahrnehmung des anderen einzunehmen und nicht nur zu sagen, ich warte jetzt bis der Ball runterfällt, dann mache ich ihn rein, sondern er ist schon sehr mannschaftsdienlich und nicht zu unterschätzen, hat auch schon einige Tore aufgelegt. Und um nochmal auf das Thema Integration zu kommen, als ich mit Paul Fernie, dem sportlichen Leiter, gesprochen hatte, hat er das Beispiel erwähnt, als letztes Jahr Kilian Corredor kam. Also er spricht weder Englisch noch Deutsch, relativ schwierig, auch im Kader oder im Staff war wenig, bevor Kofel kam, an Sprachkompetenz da, um ihn wirklich so gut ankommen zu lassen. Und dann hat er Paul Fernie an die Mannschaft gesagt, es ist unsere verdammte Aufgabe, ihn hier zu integrieren. Also er hat an die Mannschaft appelliert, den Spieler hier das Ankommen so gut wie möglich zu ermöglichen. Und das zeigt ja auch, das scheint offenbar geglückt zu sein. Zumindest ist er nach wie vor da. Er hat sich nicht nach einem Jahr zurückverabschiedet oder einen anderen Weg eingeschlagen, sondern da ist einfach womöglich auch eine gewisse Sozialkompetenz am Start, die ihm es hier erlaubt zu performen. Und insofern ist das schon mal ganz gut. Und ich denke an der Stelle, Kose Schapo und Poffe und ich meinte auch, bei dem Scouting ist es für sie wichtig, dass der Spieler nicht nur von seinen sportlichen Qualitäten reinpasst, sondern auch von seinen menschlichen. Das finde ich schon mal eine Aussage, die mich in der Klarheit sehr überrascht hat.
Ich finde es auch spannend, Luca Marseila, der war ja, dass der bei euch auch so wieder reingefunden hat, diese Lorbeeren, die er hatte, bevor er nach Paderborn gegangen ist, dann zu Viktoria Köln den Umweg genommen hat, um dann wieder hochzukommen, der bei quasi gar keine Chance hatte, nach einem Testspiel quasi unten durch war.
Hat er mir auch gesagt, ja.
Ja, also das finde ich beachtlich. Und das ist ja immer das, wenn du diese Spieler in deinem Konzept einbringen kannst und wie du sagst, ihnen das Gefühl gibst, dass sie wertvoll für dich sind, dass du sie verstehst, wie sie ticken und wie sie vielleicht anders auch angefasst werden müssen. Und damit das klappt, dann hast du einfach mit dieser Sozialkompetenz einen riesigen Vorteil gegen jemand anderen, die das nicht tun. Das ist jetzt vielleicht ein phrasenschwein Spruch, aber das sind mindestens 50 Prozent des ganzen Erfolgs.
Genau.
Und dann vielleicht als letzten Aspekt, dann können wir es fast auch schon abbinden. Auch da meint sie Paul Fernie, es ist so, dass die Ligien jetzt nicht den größten Budget haben. Sie haben zwar einmal in der Bundesliga gespielt, aber das hat nicht dazu beigetragen, jetzt Reichtümer anzuhäufen. Er macht zumindest in Gesprächen mit Ligakonkurrenz schon aus, da ist doch ein bisschen mehr vorhanden als hier am Böllnfalltor. Aber deshalb müssen sie kreativer sein. Das waren seine Worte. Wenn Darmstadt vorankommen will, dann müssen sie kreativer sein als andere Teams, die mehr Budget verfügen. Das hat sich jetzt in der Verpflichtung von zwei Japanern wohl unter anderem ausgeschlagen oder niedergeschlagen. Er war mal Chefscout bei Red Bull New York. Er erkennt auch andere Möglichkeiten. Gleichwohl mit der Salary Cup dort auch nicht alles möglich. Aber er hat auch schon mal über den Tellerrand deutlich hinausgeguckt und weiß einfach, trotz seines jungen Alters, worauf es ankommt. Und im Moment kann man mit so einer Herangehensweise durchaus einverstanden sein. Natürlich bedarf es dann, andere Kulturen auch im Kader mit zu integrieren. Und das scheint für das erste auch zu glücken. Also insofern bin ich gespannt, wie es weitergeht.
Auch da kann ich den in dem Fall eher negativen Vergleich zu Hertha WSC ziehen. Diese Integration von Spielern aus dem Ausland funktioniert in den letzten Jahren bei Hertha zum Beispiel insgesamt nicht sonderlich gut. Also ihr habt die Namen vielleicht schon mal gehört. Torstein, Sonnen, Buchalakis, Bilal Hussein und so weiter. Davon hat nicht ein Transfer funktioniert. Nicht einer, sodass man in diesem Sommer quasi den radikalen Schritt gegangen ist, zu sagen, wir holen jetzt eigentlich nur Spieler, die weder die Sprache sprechen, oder sich sehr gut in diesen ersten drei Ligen Deutschlands auskennen, um schnell anzukommen. Dann sind eher so Leute gekommen wie Niklas Kolbe, Leon Jensen, Sebastian Gröning. Also da tat man sich zuletzt zum Beispiel nicht mehr zugetraut, auf diesen kreativeren Märkten zuzuschlagen, weil da irgendeine Komponente in der Mannschaft, dem Verein aktuell fehlt, um diese Spieler ankommen zu lassen und ihr Potenzial entfalten zu lassen. Also ja, es kann so und so gehen. Bei Darmstadt ist es so, dass die nächsten drei Spiele Dynamo, Dresden, Holstein, Kiel und Magdeburg sind. Buntes Programm. Und man wird sehr gespannt sein, wo es dann hingeht. Für mich ist Darmstadt jetzt schon auf jeden Fall ein Kandidat für die– also obere Tabellenhälfte muss es sein, wie ich finde. Und ab Top 6 ist, finde ich, erst mal alles möglich. Das hat dieser Saisonstart schon gezeigt, diese Stabilität, die sie dazu gewonnen haben. Und sie hatten ja auch schon schwere Gegner, teilweise, vor allem in Kaiserslautern. Dementsprechend sieht das alles nicht verkehrt aus. Wir wollen weitergehen, und wir wollen weitergehen zu einem Team, was nun Kevin gerne vorstellen darf.
Was ich gerne vorstellen darf, ja, dann würde ich die– nachdem ich letztes Mal schon gesagt habe, dass für mich auch ein Transfer mal Canova 96 der Gewinner war, quasi, die ja immer weiter nach oben stehen, den würde ich jetzt gerne aber in anderen Vereinen nennen, weil Hannover hat sicher nicht mehr– Oh, der Twist. Ja, ich bin da bei Schalke 04, und er ist für mich ein Gewinner, und zwar auch sessorübergreifend, aus viel Schelte, Schmäh und Schadenfreude. Sind sie diesen Sommer relativ cool geblieben und haben frühzeitig die Weichen gestellt, um nochmal, ja, schon einen Umbruch auch zu tätigen, aber das klug zu machen. Und an Spielern, die jetzt dann auch schon ein bisschen da sind, auch trotzdem festzuhalten, trotz aller Enttäuschung, die man sicherlich auch in der letzten Saison erfahren hat, mit großen Krisen, viele Trainer, die man verschlissen hat in den letzten Jahren. Sind sie für mich dieses Jahr schon auch ein Kandidat für die ersten drei Plätze? Ich bin relativ überzeugt von, dass das ihnen gelingen wird, weil sie auch Spiele gewinnen, die hätten sie die letzten zwei, drei Jahre alle nicht gewonnen. Natürlich haben sie jetzt in Magdeburg gewonnen, die auch arg schlecht in die Saison gestartet sind, aber trotzdem finde ich das schon beachtlich. Sie haben einfach Eckpfeiler. Sie haben nicht nur Kenan Karaman als Eckpfeiler, den man lautstark irgendwo sieht, sondern ich glaube, Ron Schallenberg ist jetzt endgültig auch angekommen als Chef im Mittelfeld, hat viel Lehrgeld zahlen müssen, in Gelsenkirchen muss man schon sagen. Loris Karius scheint echt gut jetzt in den Tritt zu kommen dort, hat einige gute Saves schon in dieser Saison gezeigt, finde ich. Sie sind so ein bisschen gerade in der Position hinter den ersten drei Plätzen, so in dieser Lauerstellung und ich glaube, sie werden da sehr vorn profitieren. Also für mich absoluter Gewinner der ersten sechs Spieltage.
Spannend. Also ich gehe mit deiner Einschätzung definitiv mit, sie als Gewinner des Saisonstarts zu betrachten. So habe ich es mir auch notiert und trotzdem würde ich ein bisschen Wasser in den Wein kippen. Aber erst mal zu den positiven Dingen, die ich gerne verstärken wollen würde. Also ich finde, dass Miron Muzlic eine goldrichtige Trainerwahl war. Da hat jetzt Frank Baumann in Funktion gutes Händchen bewiesen. Man ist ja so ganz risikogegangen, hat eine Ablöse für einen Trainer gezahlt, der mit seinem Verein abgestiegen ist. Obwohl da auch die tiefer liegenden Zahlen bewiesen haben, so schlecht war es unter ihm gar nichts, vor allem unter dem Vorgänger. Trotzdem, viel Kredit hatte Miron Muzlic erst mal nicht. Und ich finde, dass das aber super passt. Zum einen kommunikativ, das ist ein super guter Kommunikator. Sowohl nach innen als auch nach außen macht er diesen Verein deutlich. Er zündet das an, ohne zu überhitzen. Wirkt sympathisch, wirkt nahbar. Und wenn man das vor allen Dingen mit den letzten beiden Trainern vergleicht, die auch keine Muttersprachler waren und da war es sowieso schwierig, ist das eine völlig andere Präsenz. Aber eine, die es auf Schalke einfach braucht. Du brauchst einen Trainer, der Medienarbeit kann. Du brauchst einen Trainer, der mit Charakteren kann. Und da finde ich passt Muzlic sehr, sehr gut. Und das andere ist, diese Floskel muss fallen, Malocha-Fußball. Der Fußball von Miron Muzlic passt erst mal zu dem, was man auf Schalke als Grundtugenden begreift. Er spielt einen Fußball, der vor allen Dingen auf Kampf ausgelegt ist, der vor allen Dingen auf Arbeit gegen den Ball ausgelegt ist. Und das ist eine Idee, hinter der die Mannschaft bislang versammeln konnte und daran. Und deshalb gewinnen sie Spiele. Kevin, wie du es richtig gesagt hast, dass sie sie in der letzten Saison nicht gewonnen hätten, weil du jetzt so eine einende Idee hast. Das war vorher nicht so. Vorher saß Vogelwild auf dem Platz aus.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die Mannschaft steht jetzt mit da drinnen wieder. Sie setzen das auch um. Sie sind vielleicht ein bisschen abgerückt von diesem Schalke muss jetzt sofort wieder in die 1. Liga hoch. Müssen sie natürlich auch, das ist jetzt unweigerlich. Aber sie gehen anders damit um. Das hat den HSV auch ein paar Jahre gekostet und gedauert, bis sie das begriffen haben, wie sie da wieder hinkommen, wo sie hin wollen. Ich habe gerade das Gefühl, nachdem ich das letztes Jahr beim HSV hatte, Schalke ist vielleicht noch nicht ganz so weit wie der HSV. Aber ich glaube schon, dass sie gerade im Mittelfeld und auch zum Beispiel mit der Rückkehr von Timo Becker wirklich gute Griffe getätigt haben. Im Mittelfeld mit Schallenberg, Anfija, zwei Typen, die früher schon zusammengespielt haben. Das passt schon ganz gut. Eine Säule mit Kenan Karaman habe ich schon gesagt. Loris Karius ist auch ein Typ einfach im Tor.
Zilla ist geblieben.
Zilla ist geblieben, genau. Und das könnten wir jetzt so weiter. Hier El Fahusi ist auch ein toller Transfer. Ich kann Fynn Porath, muss man mal gucken, hat jetzt nicht die Top-Mega-Überrag-Leistungen gebracht bisher, aber auch da meiner Ansicht nach ein guter Transfer. Ja, aber ich bin bei dir. Also das ist schon ein gutes Merkmal, wenn der Trainer ein Erkenntnis hat, die auf die Mannschaft überbringt. Und du hast es jetzt in Magdeburg gesehen. Da hat ja auch der Kicker gleich aufgegriffen, hier mit Torbann Rollen Schallenberg geblutet und Kämpferfußball, die haben es durchgeflogen.
Na klar, Maloha.
Und damit spielen sie auch wieder. Haben sie auch direkt selber gepostet.
Als Kind auf Kohle geboren, natürlich. Das steht aus der Frage.
Aber Rollen Schallenberg ja auch erzählt, er hat als Kind in Schalkebettwäsche geschlafen insofern.
Logisch, natürlich. Also das ist ja vollkommen klar. Aber Fußball funktioniert viel über Erzählung, es ist so. Und darüber zündet man ein Umfeld auch an. Jetzt kommen wir vielleicht ein Stück weit zu dem angesprochenen Wasser im Wein. Denn ich glaube, so gut der Saisonstart war und so sehr, ich glaube, dass Schalke eine Saison spielen wird, in der sie wenig bis gar nichts mit dem Abstieg zu tun haben werden. Und das ist ein massiver Fortschritt im Vergleich zu den letzten beiden Jahren. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie ein Team für die ersten drei Plätze sind. Und das liegt vor allen Dingen an der Spielweise mit Ball. Spielerisch, das muss man schon sagen, ist es. Und auch das war aber auch zu erwarten unter Muzlic. Da hat er auch noch nicht viel anderes auf seinen bisherigen Station gezeigt. Es ist schon irre dünn teilweise. Und da profitiert man sehr von der individuellen Klasse eines Zillers, eines Karamans. Man ist Platz 12 bei den Expected Goals. Man ist Platz 12 bei den Ballkontakten im gegnerischen Strafraum. Man hat mit Abstand die schwächste Passquote in der Liga, den geringsten Ballbesitz zusammen mit Braunschweig bei dem KSC. Es ist ein intensiver, gut organisierter Pressing-Fußball. Man hat die meisten Technik, weil man auch sehr viel Mann gegen Mann spielt und das ist gerade auch wieder ein bisschen en vogue. Da passt man den Zeitgeist, aber offensiv ist es schon sehr abhängig von individuellen Glanzmomenten, weil ich das systematisch in meinen Augen erkenne ich da bislang sehr, sehr wenig. Offensive, Kettelmann hat das jetzt bei Paderborn auch gesagt, Offensive dauert immer länger als Defensive. Da darf sich was entwickeln, das stelle ich gar nicht in Frage. Aber ich finde schon, und das hat auch Fipsa im Forum angesprochen, das Auftragsprogramm, das sah zunächst schwer aus mit Teams wie Hertha oder ähnliches. Aber diese Teams, das hat sich alles ein Stück weit relativiert, weil man jetzt sieht, wo diese Teams stehen und dass sie es allgemein schwierig hatten. Und vielleicht hat Schalke sie zu einem günstigen Zeitpunkt erwischt. Und man hat zwar gewisse Hausaufgaben erfüllt, aber geglänzt hat man bislang nun wirklich nicht. Und man hat jetzt spannende Spiele gegen Fürth, Bielefeld, Hannover und dann zweimal Darmstadt erst in der Liga, dann im Pokal. Das sind Spiele, die, glaube ich, eine sehr, sehr gute Standortbestimmung dafür sein werden, wo es mit Schalke in diese Saison hingehen kann. Und dann würde ich sehr gerne nochmal darüber reden, ob sie wirklich ganz oben angreifen können. Da bin ich stand jetzt, bei allem Lob, was ich eben geäußert habe, skeptisch, weil mir da noch ein Schritt fehlt.
Ja, ist klar. Also, bin ich bei dir, wenn du jetzt gegen Fürth und in Bielefeld gewinnst, hast du, glaube ich, auch langsam das Selbstbewusstsein. Du musst ja auch immer gucken, wo kommen sie her, ne? Selbstbewusstsein war ja quasi da nieder. Es war ja bei minus 100 und nicht bei null, sondern es war ja auf Schalke bei minus 100. Also, das war wirklich im Tagebau irgendwo angekommen. Da ging gar nichts mehr. Die waren– Also, Ende letzten Woche, ich habe es nur überall mitbekommen, ja, die steigen in dritte Liga ab. Und das ging ja durch die Bank. Haben sie es geschafft, die Klasse zu halten? Aber wirklich sehr, sehr knapp. Und dafür, finde ich, ob das jetzt Teams waren, die wanken. Ich meine, Paderborn hat auch gegen Bochum und Berlin und Co. gespielt. Also, weiß aber, was du meinst. Also, wenn sie das jetzt schaffen gegen Fürth am Freitag– Freitag, glaube ich. Freitag, ne? Kommt Freitag.
Das könnte sein. Ich checke es.
Wenn sie es da schaffen, umzusetzen und dann in Bielefeld, wo es auch nicht so leicht ist, dort die Punkte mitzunehmen, glaube ich, werden sie auch das erste Host sein haben, dann ein bisschen die Spiele, die noch attraktiver zu gestalten. Wenn sie es überhaupt brauchen, bin bei dir, dann kommen die sogenannten Wochen der Wahrheit mit Hannover und zweimal Darmstadt.
KSC danach, Elbersberg.
Ja, klar. Aber gut, das hast du in der 2. Liga eigentlich…
Das ist so, ja. Ja, voll. Aber du hast recht. Es ist Freitagabend gegen Goethe-Fürth und dann gegen Amida Bielefeld. Teams, die eher jeweils nicht wollen und selber auf Umschaltsituation setzen und da ist dann eben die Frage, passt das mit der Spielanlage da? Das ist aber auch eben die schwerste Disziplin im Fußball. Tiefgehende Gegner mit ruhigem Ballbesitz zu knacken, das ist nun mal das Schwerste, aber genau deswegen glaube ich, wird es schwer, aber es wird gleichzeitig sehr interessant zu sehen sein, ob Schalke dem irgendwann gewachsen sein wird. Matthias, hast du noch Gedanken zu den Königsblauen oder wollen wir voran schalten?
Also ein paar Gedanken schon noch. Ich fand das Spiel jetzt am Wochenende in Magdeburg, klar Magdeburg auch in einer unangenehmen Situation, aber dennoch fand ich, war das eine sehr erwachsene Leistung. Also sie haben effizient gespielt. Wenn ich das mit dem ersten Spiel gegen die Hatta vergleiche, das war ja Sturm und Drang. Ja, also sehr viel Wucht und Leidenschaft und ich glaube, das, was die Leute einfach am ersten Spieltag, Freitagabend total angezündet hat. Also da war der Schulterschluss zum Publikum sofort da und hingegen war das jetzt natürlich auch auswärts in Magdeburg, aber dennoch finde ich eine Entwicklung in gewisser Maße. Also man kommt nicht nur über die Emotionen ins Spiel rein und zieht es dann für sich, sondern man hat an der Stelle dann zum richtigen Moment das Tor gemacht und hat das Spiel dann soweit einigermaßen kontrolliert und nichts anbrennen lassen. Und dennoch bin ich tatsächlich auch eher ein bisschen skeptisch, wie weit es denn trägt. Also wenn Schalke irgendwann mal gegen das Saisonende tatsächlich noch oben mitwirken kann, dann ist die Frage, wie das Umfeld dann auf das Team einwirkt. Also wirkt es beflügelnd oder wirkt es ein bisschen lähmend, weil die Erwartungshaltung dann ist, ja, wir gehen eh hoch oder wir müssen hoch oder sonst was. Da bin ich tatsächlich gespannt, wie sich das Ganze darstellt. Aber auch Muslice hat bei mir bislang so aus der Ferne einen einigermaßen guten Eindruck hinterlassen, was ich alleine gestern bei der 1-0-Führung zeigte, weil er da einfach nur die Faust geballt hat und sehr fokussiert und klar war. Also er hat nicht sich jetzt von seinen Emotionen tragen lassen, sondern er war so nach dem Motto stark. Das haben wir jetzt erst mal gut gelöst. Und jetzt gilt es aber dran zu bleiben.
Genau, er zündet an, ohne selbst zu überdrehen. Das finde ich.
Genau.
Ja.
So würde ich es auch betrachten.
Absolut. Also Schalke geht Schritte und kommt vielleicht mal weg von dieser Herzinfarktphase, die es jetzt in den letzten zwei Jahren erlebt hat. Und das Umfeld kommt mal ein bisschen zur Ruhe. Allein das hilft ja schon immens. Wie weit diese Schritte dann reichen werden, werden wir dann in den nächsten Wochen, auch hier im Rasenfunk natürlich, beobachten. Dann würde ich sagen, mach ich doch einfach mal weiter. Und wenn wir schon bei großen Vereinen sind und Emotionen und großer Historie, dann sind wir auch schnell beim 1. Elfsteg Kaiserslautern. Und die Roten Teufel habe ich wiederum bei mir in meiner Gewinnerliste dabei. Noch auch da nicht mit dem größten Ausrufezeichen, aber wenn man sich die letzten Wochen anguckt, würde ich das unter die Überschrift packen, die Lieberknecht DNA ist angekommen. Wenn man sich das anguckt, wie er in der letzten Saison kam und dann ja auch die schwere Aufgabe hatte, er sollte ja wirklich noch mal den Aufstieg angreifen, dann hat das nicht funktioniert. Dann war das für den Moment, hat das nicht funktioniert. Und auch jetzt kam Lautern holprig in die Saison rein. So holprig, dass manche schon gesagt haben, also gefühlt ist diese Lieberknecht-Nummer auch schon wieder durch. Irgendwie wirkt die jetzt schon auserzählt. Aber sie ist es anscheinend nicht. Denn wie gesagt, ich habe das Gefühl, dass in Lautern allmählich diese Spielweise unter Lieberknecht, Matthias, du kennst sie aus Darmstadt bestens, dort jetzt angekommen ist, will sagen, es ist eine sehr intensive Spielweise gegen den Ball, hohes pressigen Situativ und dann einfaches, sehr vertikales Spiel nach vorne mit vielen Flanken. Und so hat man jetzt auch am 6. Spieltag Münster wirklich sehr überzeugend mit 4 zu 1 auf den Betze geschlagen. Man hat die Preußen teilweise, wie ich finde, überrollt. Die kamen damit nicht klar mit dieser Wucht. Und mit nun 12 Punkten aus sechs Spielen kann man sich vorerst oben festbeißen. Natürlich hast du so Gesichter des Aufschwungs, also vor allen Dingen zu nennen natürlich mit dem Stürmer Ivan Bretaljen. Fünf Tore, eine Vorlage hat jetzt dreifach getroffen gegen Münster, also komplett angekommen. Nathan Sküté drei Tore gemacht, hat erstmal Marlon Ritter, der nun wirklich ein sehr verdienter Spieler in Kaiserslautern ist, auf die Bank verbannt, und Rechtsverteidiger Paul Jolie vier Vorlagen in drei Spielen, allesamt Neuzugänge. Die sind allesamt eingeschlagen bislang. Also das funktioniert und lässt Kaiserslautern jetzt eben langsam ins Rollen kommen. Matthias, du hast gesagt, so ein bisschen beginnt auch mit dem Spiel gegen Darmstadt. Hat sich vielleicht auch da was zum Kopf gelöst, eine Selbstverständlichkeit eingestellt, und jetzt folgt man diesem Plan des Trainers deutlich mehr. Auch da würde ich Vorsicht walten lassen, denn dieser Saisonstart, das da heuprig begann, das war auch nicht von ungefähr, sondern das liegt auch daran, dass mit Ball oft eine Idee unter Lieberknecht fehlt. Und auch daran wird Kaiserslautern diese Saison, glaube ich, noch oft genug zu knabbern haben. Wenn das eben nicht durch einen Malernrüttler oder ähnliches individuell aufgelöst werden kann, wenn man nicht so einen Sahnetag erwischt, nicht jede Flanke gleich Kopfballtor ist, dann wird das auch mal wieder richtig zäh. Und deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob ich Kaiserslautern jetzt ganz oben mit reinzählen würde. Aber deswegen habe ich ein bisschen weiter vorne angefangen. Wenn man sich die bisherige Historie der Amtszeit von Lieberknecht anguckt, dann ist für mich Kaiserslautern ein Gewinner des frühen Saisonstarts. Matthias, wie siehst du das?
Ja, also ich war bislang, also zumindest vor diesem Spieltag jetzt gegen Münster, der überzeugende Sieg, den du angesprochen hast, war ich nicht so ganz überzeugt von dem, was Kaiserslautern geboten hat. Ich habe das Spiel gegen Elbersberg vor Augen. Das war gar nicht gut. Da hatten sie diverse, ja, wie soll man sagen, sie haben nicht überzeugt, weil sie einfach zu viele offene Punkte hatten in dem Auftritt, die die Mannschaft vor Ort gezeigt hat. Dazu noch bei dem nächstgelegenen Kontrahenten, der kleine Empörkömmling, den man, glaube ich, schon gerne in die Schranken weisen will, hat man da gar nicht geschafft. Und dann das darauffolgende Spiel gegen Darmstadt, nach 84 Minuten 1-0 hinten, da hat für mich wirklich nichts dafür gesprochen, dass da noch was anbrennt. Und dann hat Darmstadt irgendwann nach dem Ausgleich den Kopf verloren. Und Kaiserslautern war wirklich dann in den letzten 15 Minuten mit der Nachspielzeit einfach Oberwasser und hat dann noch drei Tore geschossen und alle drei durch Einwechselspieler in erster Linie durch Sküthe, der damals für Marlon Ritter rein kam und seitdem ihm ein bisschen den Rang abgelaufen hat. Also es zeigt schon, dass da auch Leute an Bord kamen, die die Mannschaft weiterbringen können. Und deshalb glaube ich schon, dass Lauchern was vorhat. Ganz ehrlich, wer sich mal die Transfers anschaut, sie haben mit Sküthe und auch noch mit zwei weiteren Neuzugängen, Schahin und Bretain für drei Spieler jeweils mehr als eine Million ausgegeben. Das ist für einen Zweitligisten relativ unüblich. Also nur Kiel und Düsseldorf haben in ähnlichen Maßen sich verstärkt.
Haben immerhin auch ein bisschen Geld eingenommen für Calla von Ache. Das stimmt.
Aber dennoch, da ist schon für mich auch das Zeichen da, dass man investiert, um den nächsten Schritt zu tun. Also die hatten, wir erinnern uns, vor zwei Jahren durchaus zu strugglen, in der Liga zu bleiben. Haben aber durch den Einzug ins Pokalfinale, glaube ich, nochmal einem lauteren Fan-Umfeld sehr viel Balsam auf die Seele gegeben. Und dadurch war dann letzte Saison ein bisschen das Feld bereitet, um eine bessere Saison zu spielen. Und am Ende hat es nicht gereicht. Ich glaube auch zu Recht nicht gereicht. Und jetzt haben sie aber durchaus auch Qualität. Also sie hatten ja von Augsburg und dann von Fürth, wie hieß der Verteidiger, der jetzt einen Kreuzbandriss hat.
Ach so.
Wir haben ihn alle im Kopf. Auf jeden Fall hat er sich verletzt. Und für ihn haben sie dann noch mal nachjustieren müssen und haben aus Frankreich dann einen Außenspieler verpflichtet, der auch sehr viel, also Simon Astor. Genau, Simon Astor. Und ich rede von dem Ersatz des Neuzugangs, nämlich von Jolie, der auch über die Außen durchaus auffällig agiert und da das Spiel mitgestaltet. Und ich finde, sie haben auch zentral mit Lucas Sirich oder Fabian Kunze und Semih Sahin Leute, die es für meinen Begriff verstehen, das Spiel in den Griff zu bekommen, den Gegner einzubremsen, aber auch selbst kreativ zu werden. Also insofern, da ist schon einiges bereitet im Kader, um eine bessere Rolle zu spielen. Und vor allem damals gegen die Ligien, drei Spieler, die ins Spiel kamen, haben alle drei getroffen und das Spiel sozusagen gedreht. Also sie sind auch im Stande, durchaus von der Bank noch was zu bringen. Und wenn man jetzt einen Marlon Ritter auf der Bank hat, der bei den allermeisten anderen Zweitligisten eine wesentliche Rolle spielen würde, dann ist es auch schon mal nicht gering zu schätzen. Also da ist ein bisschen was bereitet. Und du sprichst lieber Knecht an. Er hat auch zu mir mal gemeint, als ich ihn gefragt habe, will er lieber mit seinem Team Fehler erzwingen oder Fehler vermeiden, dann sagt er, er lieber Fehler erzwingen. Und das spricht ja für dieses draufgehen und versuchen, den Gegner zu stressen und mit vertikalen Spiel auch womöglichen da herlaufen zu lassen. Also insofern, ob das wirklich für ganz oben reicht, ich bin noch ein bisschen vorsichtig. Aber zumindest im Moment haben sie es geschafft, einen kleinen Lauf zu generieren. Also gleichwohl begünstigt durch den frühen Platzverweis oder frühestmöglichen Platzverweis beim vorletzten Spielen, Viert. Nichtsdestotrotz haben sie jetzt auch Münster, finde ich, gut ausgeguckt mit Flanken wechseln und Flanken. So die bunten Punkte sehr schnell erkannt und aufgedeckt. Und mit Skitäts glaube ich wirklich einen Unterschiedspieler in ihrem Kader. Also darf man gespannt sein, wo die Reise hingeht. Die Heimstärke ist das Faustpfand. Mal gucken, was sie auswärts machen.
Richtig. Kevin, wenn du jetzt keine Riesenpunkte zu Kaiserslautern hast, würde ich aus Zeitgründen so ein bisschen voranschreiten und dich dann bei den weiteren Teams reinholen. Wie siehst du das?
Sehr gerne.
Sehr gerne. Gut, dann lasst mich einmal kurz noch abhandeln, dass natürlich Hannover 96 und Amina-Wielefeld auch zu den Gewinnern der Saisonstart zählen. Ich habe nur das Gefühl bei den beiden Teams, dass über die auch in anderen Formaten und generell in der Berichterstattung schon sehr viel geredet wird und wir vielleicht gar nicht einen riesen Mehrwert an dieser Stelle noch liefern müssen und uns deswegen vielleicht eher auf Teams konzentrieren, die noch gar nicht so viel Erwähnung gefunden haben. Natürlich kann man bei Hannover darüber reden, dass es beeindruckend ist, wie schnell diese Mannschaft nach diesem radikalen Umbruch und dem Trainerwechsel zu sich gefunden hat, trotz der Niederlage jetzt gegen Hertha und dem heutigen Unentschieden gegen Dresden und dass sie den wahrscheinlich besten Fußball dieser Liga spielen. Man muss auch bei Aminia Bielfeld darüber reden. Das ist ein bisschen das Belgien der zweiten Liga. Das war von so vielen als Geheimtipp irgendwie eingestellt, dass Bielefeld doch kein Name war. Also hatte ich das Gefühl, es ist eben doch nicht der typische Aufsteiger. 10 Punkte nach 6 Spielen, dazu wäre dann ein Pokal geschlagen. Intensive Spielweise, tödliche Umschaltmomente, so wie sie eben auch im Pokal aufgetreten sind, gestalten sie die Ligaspiele. Aber dieses Spiel gegen Fürth, wie ich finde, hat am Freitagabend auch gezeigt, wie man Aminia das Leben schwer machen kann. Tiefer stehen, Bielefeld den Ball überlassen und auf Konter lauern. Und so hat dann Fürth verdient, wie ich finde, 3 zu 1 auf der Alm gewonnen, weil sie ihren Spielstil besser durchgedrückt bekommen haben. Also wie gesagt, auch über Bielefeld und Hannover wird in diesem Podcast noch oft genug geredet werden. Und das ist ja auch schon in den letzten Wochen passiert, auch bei den Gewinnern der Transferphase beispielsweise. Also liebe Bielefeld-Fans, liebe Hannover-Fans, seht es uns nach, wenn ihr heute nicht so viel Lobpreisung bekommt. Ihr kriegt das ja schon die ganze Zeit und werdet das auch wieder abbekommen. Lasst uns lieber zu den Verlierern, wenn ihr jetzt keine großen Teams mehr auf der Liste habt zumindest, oder übergehe ich gerade ein Team, wo ihr sagt, da müssen wir drüber reden.
Ich darf ja nicht.
Du darfst ja nicht. Ich habe dir heute eine SC-Paderborn-Riegel vorgeschoben, weil ich im Vorgespräch, müsst ihr wissen, habe ich gesagt, 11 Punkte nach 6 Spielen, bei allen Trainerwechseln und so weiter, das ist mittlerweile keine große Sensation in Paderborn mehr. Das spricht ja auch für die gute Arbeit der letzten Jahre.
Ist okay, nehmen wir heute so mit. Ja, alles gut.
Auch da, die Momente werden kommen, Kevin, die Momente werden kommen.
Aber da darf ich vielleicht noch kurz ein bisschen Lob holen. Also Paderborn ist einfach wirklich mittlerweile ja ein Stammgast in der ersten Tabellenhälfte der 2. Liga. Also wir erinnern uns vielleicht ein paar Jahre zurück, da war die Endplatzierung entweder 2. und sie gingen rauf oder 18. und sie gingen runter. Inzwischen ist es ganz fest, 1. Tabellenhälfte, 2. Liga und die sind für mich auch durch die handelnden Personen außerhalb des Platzes einfach sehr gut aufgestellt. Sie wissen es, Leute, die den Verein verlassen, weil sie zu höheren Berufen sind, immer wieder adäquat zu ersetzen. Und wenn ich mir anschaue, dass sie Grimmaldi auf dem letzten Drücker für mehr Geld verkaufen, als ihr teuerster Zugang gekostet hat, dann muss ich sagen, das ist auch so für meinen Begriff als Außenstehender typisch Paderborn, weil sie es doch einfach verstehen, entwicklungsfähige, unterklassige Spieler zu holen. Wir erinnern uns, letztes Jahr kam Zehntner und keiner hat ihn gekannt. Dann verkaufen sie ihn für ein paar Millionen nach Wolfsburg. Das ist einfach für mich so Paderborn. Anderswo wird ein Spieler geholt als Ergänzungsspieler. In Paderborn sind sie dazu berufen, Leistungsträger zu werden. Da muss ich schon sagen, im Scouting macht der Verein einiges richtig. Er ist ein professionelles, ruhiges Umfeld. So würde ich es bewerten.
Das Elbersberg Ostwestfalsch. Der Maulkorb für Kevin tut gerade sehr gut. Ansonsten durfte ich mir sonst was anhören. Lasst uns weitergehen, Kevin. Ich nehme dich jetzt direkt von alleine bei den, ich sage mal, Verlierern. Das ist immer so despektierlich. Aber den Teams, die eben nicht so gut reingestattet sind, über welches Team würdest du da als erstes reden wollen?
Echt schwierig, weil da ein paar dabei sind, von denen ich es nicht gedacht hätte. Ich hätte jetzt fast Fortuna Düsseldorf genannt, aber eigentlich mit sieben Punkten. Könnte man auch sagen, ja, ist ein bisschen stotterig, aber wird schon. Aber sie sind schon für mich unerwartet soweit unten. Sie haben aber natürlich auch ein paar sehr, sehr wichtige Spieler verloren. Ganz enttäuschend ist für mich aber der FC Magdeburg. Das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Also das muss man sagen. Der Tabellenplatz ist echt krass. Nach der letzten Sauer, klar, da hat es am Ende auch ein bisschen gestottert. Sie sind lange auf der Euphoriewelle gesurft. Auch der Thomas, der auch hier Mitglied im Rasenfunk ist, quasi im All-Star-Team, hat auch immer gesagt, ja, also das ist schon deutlich höher über unserem Niveau. Aber dass die jetzt gerade so Probleme haben nach dem nach dem Abgang vom Tiz auch, hat mich schon sehr beherrscht. Ein Sieg und dann aber auch fünf Niederlagen, also nicht mal irgendwie in eine Region mitgenommen. Aber es ist auch sehr schade, weil ich das sehr gerne gesehen habe, wie sich das in den letzten Jahren dort entwickelt hat. Ich kann gerade nicht so ganz festmachen, müsste man mit Thomas natürlich nochmal sprechen, ist ja viel besser geeignet dafür, aber ich kann gerade nicht so ganz festmachen, woran das überhaupt liegt bei denen.
Ich habe so eine Theorie.
Ja, dann unterbreche ich mich gerne.
Denn auch ich habe Magdeburg ja zwangsläufig bei den Verlierern des Saisonstarts. Und es ist richtig, die tun sich nach dem Titsabgang immens schwer, sich zu finden. Es sieht selten wirklich schlecht aus, aber es fehlen immer die entscheidenden Prozentpunkte. Und das ist so ein bisschen das, was ich in der Saisonprognose befürchtet hatte. Diese Mannschaft ist individuell, bis auf ganz wenige Spieler– das ist meine persönliche Meinung logischerweise– nicht sonderlich gut. Und braucht deshalb einen sonderlich guten Trainer, der das Maximum aus ihnen rausholt. Und das war Tietz in den letzten Jahren. Und das geschieht unter Markus Fiedler, seinem Nachfolger bislang noch nicht. Das heißt nicht, dass Markus Fiedler kein guter Trainer ist. Aber es ist ein deutlich unerfahrener Trainer, der noch nie auf Zweitliganiveau trainiert hat. Und der diese Mannschaft auch erstmal kennenlernen muss. Und dann holst du die ersten Ergebnisse nicht und dann wickelt sich diese Negativ-Spirale. Und ich habe mir das mal angeguckt. Du hast durch die Abgänge von Kars, El Hankouri und Bocu insgesamt 48 Torbeteiligungen verloren aus dem letzten Jahr. Das ist krass. Und du hast das ersetzt durch– und das ist auch Magdeburg typisch und auch das ist auch Zweitiger typisch– durch eher durch Spieler, die Perspektivspieler sind, die irgendwann ankommen sollen. Aber welche krassen Säulen hast du in dieser Mannschaft? So viele sind das nicht, auch weil ich das Gefühl habe, also Baris Atiks Klasse, die ist sicherlich individuell noch da, aber er wird älter. Und ich habe das Gefühl, man hat das Beste von ihm gesehen. Und ich finde, in den letzten anderthalb Jahren oder so, kommt immer weniger von ihm. Das ist jetzt auch da. Das ist eher so ein Bauchgefühl. Ich glaube schon, dass man das durch Scorer-Zahlen auch durchaus so sehen kann. Aber ich will sagen, die Unterschiedspieler, die Zweitiger erfahren sind, die sind in Magdeburg immer weniger geworden. Du hast jetzt erstmal einen Qualitätsverlust durch Christian Thietz, ohne wie gesagt Markus Fiedler zu nahe treten zu wollen. Und Fiedler selbst sagt, ich habe keinen Gegner gesehen, der uns vor Aufgaben stellt, denen wir nicht gewachsen sind. Das sagt er auch nach dem Schalke-Spiel. Er sieht eher oft brutale Spielverläufe und mit dem ersten individuellen Fehler geraten, wie direkt einen Rückstand. Und dann schaltet das Kopfkino natürlich bei den Beteiligten ein. Das ist jetzt auch einfach so eine Selbstbewusstseinssache. Offensiv fehlt auf die Durchschlagskraft bis auf dieses Freak-Spiel gegen Fürth. Wo du vier Tore machst, aber auch fünf kassierst. Bist du offensiv wenig da und defensiv hast du immer wieder individuelle Patzer, denen du hinterherläufst. Und dann, wie gesagt, dann kommt die Krise im Kopf an und da befindet sich jetzt Magdeburg in dieser Negativspirale.
Deswegen. Sie schlagen sich aber auch unter Wert, finde ich. Sie haben schon Spieler, die einen Unterschied machen können, finde ich. Mit Al Holmström finde ich es schon auch im Sturm jemand, da der schon auch stark ist im Mittelfeld. Lassen wir überleben. Ich weiß nie, wie man auch spricht. Luca Hüre, Leinen, den Finn.
Hüre, Leinen.
Hüre, Leinen. So. Oder Grieb. Das sind schon Spieler. Weiß ich nicht. Ich hätte diesen Verein mit dem Potenzial eher im Mittelfeld, wie gesagt, erwartet. Nicht mehr oben im Kampf drin. So ein bisschen Konsolidierung ist ja schon beifallend. Der Abgang von Kars ist natürlich brutal. Einfach zwei Tore in drei Spielen. Dann geht der nach St. Pauli. Das ist einfach übel. Deswegen muss ich so deutlich sagen, hasse ich diese Transferphase, dass sie länger geht, als die Saison statt schon ist. Ich finde, das ist ein Unding. Gerade für so einen Verein, der auch nicht unendlich Möglichkeiten hat.
Das trifft am ehesten immer die schlechteren, kleineren Vereine, weil die nicht so nachlegen können.
Einen guten Stürmer findest du halt auch nicht einfach mal dann noch so kurzfristig. Das tut Magdeburg schon enorm weh. Thomas hatte zwar zuerst ein bisschen so letztens die Hoffnung, dass das nicht so schwer ins Gewicht fällt. Weil, wie du sagst, Magdeburg ja auch teilweise ansehnliche Spielpassagen hat und das liegt dann meistens an diesem einen oder zweiten, dritten blöden Fehler, wo man sich gleich auch das Ding fängt. Aber das macht schon auch viel aus. Das ist echt, echt bitter. Ich hoffe, dass sie die Ruhe haben und das auch jetzt irgendwie mit einem schmutzigen Sieg, wie man es immer so schön sagt, oder auch mit einem euphorischen Sieg umwünschen können, weil ich finde, der FCM hat sich schon eigentlich in den letzten Jahren gut etabliert. Und ich finde es auch, unabhängig von aller Leistungsgerechtigkeit oder irgendwas, fand es toll, dass sich ein ostdeutscher Verein auch so etabliert hat. Ich bin da gerade ein bisschen enttäuscht, einfach weil ich finde das echt schade, weil das Umfeld, die Stimmung dort im Starten ist überragend. Ich glaube, die kann halt auch– das Thema hatten wir vorhin auf Schalke, du hattest gesagt, wenn der Erfolgsdruck da ist, kann das auch ein Druck werden, irgendwo so eine Kulisse zu haben. Aber vielleicht wird es auch das Ding in den nächsten Wochen, um sie wieder da raus zu pushen.
Ich denke, im Moment ist auch das Thema, du sprachst an, was gestern Markus Fiedler nach dem Spiel gesagt hat, mit den individuellen Fehlern. Und Magdeburg hat halt noch kein Spiel gedreht. Also sprich, wenn sie in den Rückstand geraten, ist das Kind eigentlich schon fast in den Brunnen gefallen. Und wahrscheinlich weiß jeder, der Magdeburg anhängt oder auf dem Platz steht. Oh man, jetzt geht die Scheiße schon wieder los. Auf gut Deutsch. Also sprich, ein 0 zu 1 ist, glaube ich, im Moment psychologisch wirklich schwer für die wegzustecken. Und ich bin gespannt, wie das in dem Konstrukt mit dem neuen Coach dann auch funktioniert. Also ist er im Stande, hier dem Team die Sicherheit zu geben, dass das Team Lösungen findet und sich aus diesem Schlamassel rausarbeiten kann. Oder ist er unter Umständen dann das schweste Glied in der Kette und wird irgendwann mal dann halt vor die Tür gesetzt, ohne ihm jetzt irgendwas an der Misere zuschreiben zu wollen. Aber natürlich wissen wir um die Verdienste von Tietz in dem Umfeld. Und jetzt ist ein neuer Coach und das läuft nicht. Also 1 zu 1 zusammenzählen, irgendwann wird so eine Debatte dann hochkochen. Deshalb ja, keine allzu gute Situation und um noch ein Gedanken zu dem längeren Transferfenster anzubringen. Also da bist du nicht allein. Kevin mit der Meinung auch, Paul Ferny von Lilian als sportlicher Leiter hatte zu mir schon im Juli gesagt, für ihn ist es ein Unding. Also er würde sagen, mit dem Anpfiff der 2. Liga oder jeglicher Liga ist das Transferfenster zu. Weil er hatte damals auch schon gesagt, normalerweise fangen dann gerade finanzkräftige Teams nochmal an, einen Stürmer zu suchen und so ist es ja. Stürmer sind einfach ein begehrtes Gut. Und wer einem eine zweistellige Anzahl von Toren garantiert, der ist schon mal fein raus. Und insofern hat jetzt Magdeburg an der Stelle leider das Nachsehen gehabt und konnte auch nicht mehr wirklich nachlegen. Also deshalb müssen sie jetzt mit dem Personal, das sie haben, erst mal zurechtkommen und ich glaube, da ist einfach im Moment auch zwischen den Ohren ziemlich viel am Struggeln und ich bin gespannt, wie sich das Team dann fängt oder festigt.
Man könnte meinen, sie hätten jetzt eine Chance. Sie fahren jetzt nach Karlsruhe, die heute auch eine Packung bekommen haben.
Aber sind aber gleichzeitig richtig heimstark.
Jaja, klar. Also das ist ungefestigtes Team, was, ja, mal gucken. Aber vielleicht ist das so das Ding auswärts, das zu ziehen. Also mit fünf Niederlagen, ich meine, Bochum hat es eher genauso hart zum Start erwischt.
Es fing ja schon am ersten Spielteil an. Wir erinnern uns gegen Braunschweig zu Hause irgendwann sogar in Überzahl und hatten davor schon das Spiel dominiert und verstehen es nicht, den Sack zuzumachen. Wir kriegen dann so einen Distanztreffer.
Es wirkt bislang einfach, als ob sie wenig Zugriff auf Spieler haben. Es ist nie richtig schlecht, aber der finale Zugriff fehlt. Wie gesagt, gespannt kann man sein, wie es dann den KSC läuft. Danach ist es Elbersberg, danach ist es Darmstadt. Also das ist schon knackig, bevor es dann am 10. Spieltag gegen Preußen Münster geht, was wiederum, glaube ich, dann ein sehr entscheidendes Spiel sein könnte. Wir wollen nicht zu weit in die Zukunft gucken, aber so ist das weitere Programm. Ich würde in meiner Liste mal weitergehen. Du hast es schon angesprochen, Kevin. Bei mir ist Fortuna Düsseldorf auch auf der Kippe. Man müsste fast drüber reden, weil heute Klaus Adolfs darin getunen, nach der 0-3-Niederlage, ja, fast schon angezählt hat, muss man sagen. Zitat, der Trainer ist verantwortlich dafür, dass sich das bessert. Und ob die Frage, wie Adolfs plant, sagt er, ich mache das jetzt nicht mit einem Endspiel. Es wäre aber auch nicht glaubwürdig, wenn ich sagen würde, der Trainer ist außerhalb jeder Diskussion. Da kann man reininterpretieren, was man möchte. Klaus Adolfs ist ein alter Hase in dem Geschäft. Der weiß ganz genau, was er mit solchen Worten sagt. Vielleicht ist das aber ein Thema, was man in den nächsten Wochen noch mal dediziert.
Stichwort Länderspielpause.
Stichwort Länderspielpause. Die nächste steht schon in den Startlöchern quasi.
Ich würde mich aber auch wundern, wenn Alofs, wir kennen womöglich noch seine Amtszeit in Bremen, also er ist ja glaube ich jemand, der Kontinuität zu schätzen weiß.
Er hat Tune 2022 selber geholt.
Ja, also er ist für mich nicht verdächtig, aktionistisch aufzutreten. Deshalb würde ich sagen, Tune ist für den Moment sehr gut.
Das glaube ich auch.
Aber Tune versucht es jetzt halt auch schon in der vierten Saison, dritten, vierten. Und man hat die letzten Jahre immer oben dran gekratzt und es nicht geschafft. Jetzt hat man echt herbe Abgänge auch gehabt, die wirklich sehr, sehr wichtig waren. Deswegen hoffe ich auch, so kenne ich Alofs auch, dass man dem Team noch Zeit gibt, einfach sich wieder zu finden. Nur es könnte natürlich passieren, wenn die jetzt vor der Länderspielpause gar nichts mehr wollen. Boah, wird es, glaube ich, echt eng für ihn.
Das ist so. Dann lasst uns aber zu einem anderen Team kommen. Und dann sind wir beim VfL Bochum. Lasst uns nun das Thema aufmachen zu später Stunde. Ich hoffe, wir kriegen das zeitlich einigermaßen gut über die Bühne. Dort hat es einen Knall gegeben, ein Beben, wie man auch immer so schön sagt, ein Personalbeben. Denn vor gut einer Woche hat man sich sowohl von Trainer Dieter Hecking als auch von Sportgeschäftsführer Dirk Dufner getrennt. Das war die Reaktion auf den sehr enttäuschenden Saisonstarten. Auf fünf Spielen hatte man nur drei Punkte, es sah nicht gut aus. Dieter Hecking hatte ja noch in der letzten Saison das Himmelfahrtskommando übernommen, um irgendwie in dieser Klasse zu halten. Auch das gelang nicht. Aber man hatte sich auf so einer Ebene gefunden, dass man dieses Projekt in der zweiten Liga zusammen angehen wollte, hat dann aber gemerkt, eine richtige Dynamik will da nicht aufkommen. Und Dirk Dufner, na ja, wenige Monate im Amt und schon wieder raus. Hertha-Fans können sich das gar nicht erklären. Der hat doch bei Hertha so gut gewirkt. Wie kann denn das bei Bochum jetzt nicht funktioniert haben? Also ich glaube, auch da hat sich vielleicht jemand erst mal ein bisschen final verbrannt. Aber ich glaube, das ist ein eigener Schwerpunkt, den man gefühlt irgendwann aufmachen müsste, wenn man dann auch irgendwann weiß, wo die Reise bei Bochum so ein bisschen hingeht. Dort war es jetzt so, dass David Siebers übernommen hat, intervimsweise. Dort wurde auch schon gesagt, dass er nicht nur das Spiel jetzt gegen Lürnberg bekommt, sondern auch die beiden weiteren Spiele gegen Düsseldorf und Kaiserslautern. Das Spiel gegen Lürnberg, quasi das Krisenduell des Spieltags. Denn auch Lürnberg stand ja vor dem Spiel wirklich nicht gut da. Das hat man verloren und nun ja. Ich finde, die Leistung gegen Lürnberg war abermals eher unterwältigend, wenn man sich so einen Effekt durch den Trainer erhofft, auch wenn die Beteiligten sich an klare Verbesserungen, sie wollen klare Verbesserungen gesehen haben. Und ja, das mag in einzelnen Momenten, pressigen Momenten, in wenigen Phasen irgendwo der Fall gewesen sein. Aber wenn man da Nürnberg im Vergleich sieht, die auch in einer schweren Situation waren, das war die deutlich reifere Spielanlage. Dementsprechend war das schon unterwältigend. Es gibt so viele Bausteine bei Bochum, man könnte wirklich eine ganze Sendung damit füllen. Vor allem offensiv ist Bochum erschreckend schwach. Sechs Tore in sechs Spielen, ein Elfmeter war aber auch dabei. Und ansonsten waren es nur Kontertore. Ja, musst du auch erst mal machen. Aber aus dem Spiel heraus geht bei Bochum eigentlich gar nichts.
Ja, und auch defensiv überhaupt nicht gefestigt. Wenn du mal anguckst, wie viele Abwehrspieler schon auf Einsatzzeiten gekommen sind. Das sind ja, wenn ich es mal eben so schlaue, ich glaube, 10 Spieler, die offiziell als Abwehrspieler nominiert sind beim Kicker im Kader, alle zum Einsatz gekommen. Das zeugt nicht davon, dass eine Abwehr steht, also dass Grundgerüst steht und drum herum, sondern das zeugt davon, dass halt experimentiert wird. Es wird noch gesucht. Man findet einfach nicht diese Konstellation, wie es passen könnte. Das ist ein großes Problem.
Ein Indiz dafür, dass man im Umbruchssommer nach dem Abstieg– und das ist dann immer naturgemäß, da haben wir drüber geredet– dann ist ein Kader auf dem Umbruch bei Bochum. Das war es auch so. Das, was du gerade angesprochen hast, die vielen Spieler zeigt eben, dass man– also für mich– und das ist auch eine Handschrift, wenn man es positiv bezeichnen möchte von Dr. Dufner– der Kader wirkt eher zusammengewürfelt, als nach einem klaren Plan zusammengestellt. Du hast das Gefühl, dass dich überall mal irgendwie bedient wurde. Ach, da ist ein irgendwie interessanter junger Spieler zur Leih, nehmen wir mit. Ach, da ist ein einigermaßen robuster Stürmer aus der Zeit in der französischen Liga. Ja, das funktioniert auch in der Regel.
Du hast im Mittelfeld zwei 19-Jährige, die alle sechs Spiele gemacht haben. Mit einem 30-Jährigen zusammen.
Und das kann funktionieren, wie gesagt, wenn das Gerüst stimmt. Aber das Gerüst musste ja ein Stück weit neu auch aufgebaut werden. Klar, du hast Timo Horn im Tor, der jetzt aber auch nicht seit sechs Jahren die absolute Nummer 1 in Bochum ist. Du hast Kevin Vogt zurückgeholt, der aber auch aus Gründen bei Bochum, bei Bochum bei Union eigentlich keine Rolle mehr gespielt hat. Den merkst du das Alter langsam an. Leute wie Maxi Wittek oder auch Philipp Hoffmann kommen nicht mehr an die Qualitäten alter Tage heran. Also diese Achse, die es geben müsste, die funktioniert nicht. Also am ehesten müsste man da eigentlich Ibrahima Sissoko und Matos Behrow dazuzählen, die im besten Fußballeralter sind, die aber gefühlt eher von dieser Negativwelle mit erwischt wurden, als voranzugehen. Und dadurch ergibt sich ein Mischmasch, wo man Dieter Hecking nicht allein verantwortlich machen darf, wobei es auch immer hieß, Dieter Hecking hat maßgeblich auch am Kader mitgewirkt. Also es war nicht nur Dirk Duffner, der da dran gearbeitet hat. Aber insgesamt passt da extrem wenig ineinander. Trotz aller Verletzungsprobleme, die der hoch im Kader hat und die man ihnen zugestehen muss, ist das in allen Mannschaftsteilen bislang wirklich zu wenig. Und ja, besorgniserregend, das muss man schon so sagen.
Extrem, extrem besorgniserregend. Sie haben hier in Paderborn gespielt, da habe ich, ich war erschrocken. Da war Vogt noch wirklich herausragend defensiv. Sonst hätte es zur Halbzeit, glaube ich, schon zwei, drei Tore mehr für einen SCP haben können. Der hat sich dann, glaube ich, dabei verletzt, musste dann durch die Halbzeit ausgewechselt werden. War bis dahin der Spieler des Spiels für mich. Aber der Elbmann ist 33 und ich bin bei dir. Also es fehlt so das Konzept. Und ich glaube, das ist wirklich auch du hast gesagt, Hacking, Duftner hast mit Hacking jemanden, der ja auch in anderen Teams, in anderen Vereinen schon da den Duftner-Posten quasi gekleidet hat, der einfach auch selbst ein Netzwerk hat an Spielern, die er kennt, an Spielerberatern. Dann hast du einen Duftner, der natürlich aber das selber tut, dann aber darauf achten muss, dass dieser Hacking mitmacht und so. Wobei ich Hacking nicht als unbequem Typen einschätze, aber so allein, diese ganze Mischung in Bochum wirkt natürlich jetzt auch nach so einem Fehlstart. Sonst würden wir vielleicht anders reden, aber beim Transferfenster habe ich es auch schon gesagt. Da hat man viele, viele junge Spieler geholt, was grundsätzlich cool ist, aber man hatte wenige Leitspieler mit viel Erfahrung und auch noch dem Skill, dem nötigen Körnern, die sie noch haben, im Team behalten, sodass sie die jungen Spieler mitziehen können. Da ist ein Gerrit Holtmann vorne drin, aber das war es dann auch.
Ja, also jeder, der das Spiel am Wochenende gegen Nürnberg gesehen hat, ich glaube, wenn du nicht gewusst hättest, wer ist hier das Team mit einem neuen Trainer und wer ist das Team, das mindestens genauso sehr unter Druck steht. Also ich finde, Nürnberg hat mit zunehmendem Spiel aber immer korrigierter gespielt und hat das Heft in die Hand genommen, hat dann lediglich im letzten Drittel, finde ich, oftmals ein bisschen zu wenig Zug zum Tor gezeigt, aber sie haben es dann trotzdem auch geschafft, in Führung zu gehen und hätten sie das Spiel wirklich mit einem Remis bestritten, dann wäre es sehr, sehr bitter gewesen, weil im Endeffekt war Nürnberg sehr viel reifer und überzeugender im Auftritt. Und bei Bochum muss ich mir wirklich Sorgen machen, muss ich sagen. Also das war ein Spiel, das überhaupt keine Aufbruchsstimmung für mich hat aufkommen lassen. Außer Eckballvarianten, bei denen Kevin Vogt mal als Eckballschütze in der Verscheinung getritt, war ja da kaum was Überraschendes dabei. Also es war tatsächlich ein sehr biederer Auftritt, finde ich. Und ihr hattet schon das Transferfenster angesprochen. Also ich hatte da gestern auch noch mal ein bisschen mein Blick schweifen lassen. Bochum hat laut transfermarkt.de tatsächlich nur 550.000 Euro für Leihgebühren oder Ablösesummen ausgegeben. Das ist das wenigste Invest aller Zweitligisten. Und das als Erstliga-Absteiger der vier Jahre, erste Liga und dementsprechend der TV-Gelder in der Hinterhand hat. Und bei den Abgängen wird es fast noch bitterer. Also es haben 13 Zweitligisten es verstanden. Ein oder mehrere Spiele für mindestens 2 Millionen zu veräußern. Und Bochum keinen.
Selbst Tim Oermann ist für 1,9 Millionen Euro zu Bayer Leverkusen gegangen.
Genau. Also das heißt, du hast vier Jahre in der ersten Liga gespielt und schaffst es nicht im Abstiegsfall, deine Kronjubiläen sozusagen noch zu Geld zu machen. Selbst Darnstadt hat es letztes Jahr– und die waren wahrscheinlich mit der schlechteste Absteiger seit langem– hat es letztes Jahr verstanden, zwei Spieler natürlich nach England zu veräußern und da fast sechs Millionen einzunehmen. Also da muss ich mich schon fragen, was da nicht so ganz aufgegangen ist.
Wenn man sich dem Bochum ein bisschen umhört, dann ist, glaube ich, das einfach auch das Ergebnis jahrelanger schlechter Arbeit, trotz einiger Klassenerhalte. Also Bochum ist ja jahrelang in der ersten Liga geblieben und niemand wusste genau, warum. Da waren da so Freak-Relegationen oder sonst was dabei. Irgendwie hat man sich gerettet, aber selbst in der ersten Liga haben ja alle einen Plan bei Bochum vermissen lassen. Man hat sich von ins nächste Jahr gesteppt und das nächste Jahr irgendwie sich da durchgehangelt. Und ich glaube, das ist das Ergebnis schlechter Arbeit. Die Fans in Bochum waren jahrelang überhaupt nicht zufrieden mit den Gremien. Und da hat es ja auch da einen radikalen Umbruch gegeben. Jetzt hast du mit Andreas Lute einen verdienten Bochumer als Vereinspräsidenten, jemand, der sehr viel jünger auch ist, der da vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen das Fenster aufmacht und frische Luft reinlässt. Denn wenn man sich mit Bochum Journalisten oder so auch unterhält, dann merkt man schon, da hat es richtig gemieft bei Bochum in den Gremien. Und da war kein Esprit, keine Vision, kein langfristiges Denken, eher die typischen Grabenkämpfen und Ego-Nummern eines Traditionsvereins, wie man das oft kennt. Und das hat Bochum sportlich jetzt einfach wehgetan und mündet irgendwann darin, wo der VfL jetzt vielleicht angekommen ist. Und jetzt muss man hoffen, dass Lute und Co. früh genug die Handbremse noch gezogen haben, erste Pflaster draufkleben können, denn die Saison läuft, du wirst jetzt schwierig Weichenstellungen betreiben können. Aber das ist jetzt erst mal das Ergebnis, was du hast. Und ich glaube, in diesem Jahr, das ist so ein bisschen wie Schalke, im ersten Jahr nach dem Abschied, das Überlebenskampf. Du musst erst mal diese Klasse halten und dann wirst du gucken, wo du hingehen musst. Und auch das werden wir in diesem Podcast sehr interessiert begleiten.
Matthias, du hast einen sehr interessanten Aspekt gerade nochmal genannt mit den Transfers. Gerrit Holtmann, der jetzt glaube ich Top-Torjäger ist mit zwei Toren, war ja eigentlich schon weg. Der wurde ja offiziell verabschiedet. Das fand ich so krass. Und auf einmal lese ich die Nachricht, Gerrit Holtmann ist jetzt doch in Bochum geblieben. Ich dachte so, was ist denn jetzt da los? Allein so was ist schon so was von skurril. Hat es das schon mal gegeben, dass ein Spieler offiziell verabschiedet wird?
Jetzt gebe ich mal kurz Insights. Als Dirk Dufner bei Hertha Kaderplaner war unter Friedi Bobic, war der letzte Transfertag. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr den Javairo Deiruzu noch kennt. Junger Niederländer damals auf dem Flügel bei Hertha, talentierter Spieler, egal, es hat nicht mehr so richtig funktioniert. Und er sollte ausgeliehen werden nach Bordeaux, wenn man sich mit einem anderen Flügelspieler schon sicher einig war. Laut eigener Aussage. Das ist dann aber kurz vor Transferende geplatzt. Und Deiruzun war auch schon auf dem Weg nach Bordeaux und man hat ihn gebeten, ihn noch mal zurück zu holen. Dass er den Flug quasi abbricht und noch mal zurückkommt. Und das ist dann nicht passiert. Und am Ende hatte Hertha keinen Flügelspieler. Also auch das passiert unter Dukdorf, und spricht für eine gewisse Planlosigkeit.
Ja, ich glaube, wir hatten es in Darmstadt auch schon mal, dass Klaus-Glias Sula nach dem Bundesliga-Abschied verabschiedet wurde mit allen anderen Abgängen am letzten Spieltag. Und dann hat man sich in der Sommerpause doch noch mal zusammengefunden. Es war aber schon so ein bisschen absehbar, dass man da das Gespräch noch mal suchen wird. Aber offiziell war er erst mal weg und ist dann doch geblieben. Oder ist noch mal angeheuert. Aber dennoch, Bochum ist für mich tatsächlich so schon erschütternd. Also ich habe auch noch mal ein bisschen nachgelesen. Angeblich, zumindest laut Fadz-Artikel, hat Geschäftsführer Ilya Kenzig gesagt, dass er mit Dieter Hecking einen Meilenstein in der Geschichte des Vereins verpflichtet hätten. Mit seiner Verpflichtung einen Meilenstein in der Geschichte des Vereins, da denke ich mir auch so, boch, das sind ganz schön große Worte. Ja, und wir haben es damals mit einem Erstligisten zu tun, der noch versucht hat, irgendwie die erste Liga zu halten. Aber im Endeffekt, wenn du Max fragen würdest, hat, glaube ich, das Ganze begonnen, in die falsche Richtung zu laufen, als sie Thomas Letsch entlassen hatten. Damals in der Relegationssaison, die dann noch gegen Düsseldorf irgendwie umgebogen wurde. Aber der hatte ja zumindest eine fußballerisch sehr klare Handschrift. Also da war das Ergebnis vielleicht dann gegen Ende der Saison nicht mehr so durchweg richtig, weshalb dann der Verein gedacht hat, okay, wir müssen hier reagieren, um die Klasse zu halten. Aber dennoch war das vielleicht ein bisschen voreilig. Und im Endeffekt ist es tatsächlich für mich nicht klar, wo Bochum jetzt hinsteuert. Und ich weiß nicht, wer von euch vor ein paar Wochen gesehen hat, wie Hermann Gerland im Sportstudio war. Trainer, Co-Trainer von Bayern etc., Jeder wird ihn kennen oder im Gesicht vor Augen haben. Der hat ja selber bei Bochum seine fußballische Sozialisation erfahren. Und der wurde darauf angesprochen, wie er denn die Chancen von Bochum einschätzte. Und der war total pessimistisch und hat gesagt, die Bundesliga-Rückkehr ist nahezu ausgeschlossen. Und zwar nicht nur in dieser Saison, sondern auf Sicht. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, puh, der kennt sicherlich noch ein paar Leute in Bochum und weiß die Situation einzuschätzen. Und der war sehr klar, wie man ihn kennt und sehr negativ. Und wenn man jetzt so ein bisschen hinter diese ganze Doppelentlassung und Hacking guckt und was da alles einfach schon im Argen liegt, dann ist man dazu geneigt zu sagen, ja, da könnte man im Moment mitgehen.
Wie gesagt, jetzt wurden ja zumindest auf Präsidiumsebene und so weiter wichtige Schritte gegangen, um da vielleicht einen Neuanfang zu starten. Aber oft, wie es ist, ist es dann vielleicht schon zu spät oder ähnliches. Das wollen wir noch nicht sagen nach dem sechsten Spieltag. Da sind noch einige Weichen zu stellen.
Das Spiel gegen Düsseldorf am Samstag, dann das Top-Spiel, das wird für beide Teams sehr spannend. Aber für ein VfL-Bohrum ist das, glaube ich, schon… Das wäre der Moment, wo du Momentum kreieren kannst, wenn du das Ding zu Hause gewinnst.
Absolut, absolut. Ich würde sagen, wir schreiten voran und kommen… Auch da würde ich vielleicht aus zeitlichen Gründen den Abbindner zum 1. FC Nürnberg machen, bevor wir zu der RTA BSC kommen, über die ich schon länger reden wollen würde. Denn auch Nürnberg ist so ein bisschen wie im positiven Hannover am Bielefeld. Es wurde schon sehr viel darüber geredet. Und jetzt nach dem Sieg gegen Bochum ist ja auch die Frage, in welche Richtung geht es. Miroslav Klose hat gesagt, ey, wir brauchen einfach nur Zeit. Diese Mannschaft hat gegen Bochum zum zweiten Mal in dieser Form zusammenspielen können. Späte Transfers, Verletzungen und so weiter. Späte Transfers, auch wie Finn-Ole Becker oder Krimal, die schlagen jetzt offensichtlich ein. Ich glaube, dass Nürnberg so eine Black Box noch ist, dass sie vielleicht ein, zwei Spieltage noch abwarten müssen, um wirklich beurteilen zu können, wo die Reise dahin geht. Denn wie gesagt, dieser Kader hat sich spät gefunden. Das ist eine junge Mannschaft mit auch einigen Spielern, die den deutschen Fußball auch noch nicht kennen. Und dieser Sieg hat jetzt zumindest ein bisschen beruhigt. Und deswegen würde ich…
Einen Satz?
Ja, machte meines Amtes sagen, wir schreiten doch ein Team weiter, außer jemand möchte unbedingt noch einen Punkt zu Nürnberg sagen.
Nur einen Satz?
Natürlich. Gerne.
Und zwar hat Miroclose die große Stärke von Grimaldi entdeckt. Du wechselst ihn kurz vor Schluss ein und er macht einen. Immer.
Ja, so einen brauchst du auch im Team.
Das ist unfassbar, der Typ. Ich war echt traurig, als der uns noch verlassen hat. Das ist eine richtige Waffe, wenn du den reinbringst. Das ist wirklich krass. Schade, ganz, ganz komisch.
Genau, also bin ich bei dir. Das war so Klose-Vibes. Du hast einen Kopfballstarken Mittelstürmer, der einfach das Ding reinwuchtet und wahrscheinlich noch den Gegenspieler mit reingewuchtet hätte. So wirkt es in der Situation. Also, ich meine, was hat man von Nürnberg erwartet? Nürnberg hat zwar viele Gelder generiert durch Transfers, aber sie haben ein rund erneuertes Team. Und wie du sagst, Mark, auch ein sehr junges Team. Also, das ist eine wahnsinnige Herausforderung für Miroclose. Und man sieht ihm ja quasi bei jedem Spiel an, was da auch für eine Last auf ihm lastet. Und wie sehr er sich mit dem Club und mit der Mannschaft identifiziert und das zum Erfolg führen will. Und insofern kann man da gestern sagen, Glück auf. Ja, auch wenn es nur der Partnerverein ist oder der befreundete Verein, der das auf seine Fahnen geschrieben hat. Klub auf. Klub auf, genau. Dass das hoffentlich sich verfestigt. Und ich finde, sie haben auch mit Markiev, mit dem Sechser, zumindest gestern einen sehr auffälligen Spieler ins Spiel bringen können. Also auch ein Last-Minute-Transfer. Sechser eben eine sehr neurologische Position für jede Mannschaft. Und ich finde, er hat Struktur, Pass-Sicherheit und Spielverständnis ins Spiel gebracht. Und da bin ich auch sehr gespannt, wie er sich weiterentwickelt. Aber für den ersten Eindruck, den ich von ihm gewonnen habe, sehr positiv.
Sehr schön. Dann haben wir doch noch kurz über den Club geredet. Wenn ich allein die Abgänge abdurchgehe. Janda, Kastrup, Zimas, Emreli, Antiest. Das ist schon richtig doll. Dazu jetzt irgendwie so jetzt der Abgesang auf Robin Knoche so ein bisschen gestartet, der letztes Jahr noch wichtig war. Also da tut sich viel im Team. Und wo sich auch viel tut, ist mal wieder in der Hauptstadt. Die Überleitung nehme ich doch gerne mit für unseren letzten Verein in dieser Liste. Hertha BSC, ja, es ist so ein Stück weit mein Steckenpferd. Ich hoffe, dass ich nicht zu sehr monologisiere. Man wollte am 6. Spieltag an das 13.0 an den Überraschungserfolg in Hannover anknüpfen und knüpfte dann aber zielsicher an die Auftritte davor an. An die katastrophalen Auftritte davor, muss man sagen. Und verlor letztendlich völlig verdient gegen ein sehr unaufgeregtes SC Paderborn mit 0 zu 2. Und in Berlin, das kann ich sagen, brennt der Baum komplett. Und das betrifft nicht mehr nur Trainer Stefan Leitel, sondern in Kürze, um das abzuwiegen, auch Sportdirektor Benny Weber, der mittlerweile, glaube ich, also dessen Schicksal mittlerweile, glaube ich, an Stefan Leitel angeknüpft ist. Um das wirklich möglichst kurz abzuhandeln, dieser Saisonstart ist eine Katastrophe. Er ist der schlechteste seit Mitte der 80er Jahre. Er hat das in vielen Städten. Es ist keine Ergebniskrise, um das mal vorwegzunehmen. Es ist nicht so, dass die nur nicht die Tore machen oder individuelle Fehler haben, wie es oft auch zum Beispiel unter Vorgänger Christian Fjell der Fall war, sondern es ist eine wirklich spielerische Krise. Er hat das in vielen Statistiken der 2. Liga, teilweise sogar letzter oder nah am letzten Platz, ob das Torgefahr ist, ob das Ballbesitz-Statistiken sind und ähnliches. Man weiß nicht so genau, was in diesem Sommer passiert ist, denn wenn man sich daran zurückerinnert, Stefan Deitel übernahm, klar, es gab so einen Schocker gegen Elbersberg, aber danach hat er diese Mannschaft sehr souverän zum Klassenerhalt geführt, Hertha war zwischenzeitlich 7 Spiele ungeschlagen, aber auch schon zum Ende der Rückrunde hatte ich irgendwie das Gefühl, mir fehlt so der nächste Step, denn eigentlich hatte Hertha nur Ruhe und du hättest eigentlich den nächsten Step taktisch einfach vorbereiten können. Und der blieb so ein Stück weit aus und ich hatte schon da irgendwie das Gefühl, ja ist jetzt alles nicht schlimm, im Sommer kann es aufgearbeitet werden, aber irgendwie wird da was liegen gelassen an Zeit. Und dann kommt Hertha aus der Sommerpause heraus und ist eigentlich einer der Top-Favoriten dieser Liga, allein was das individuelle Potenzial dieser Mannschaft angeht, denn du hast nicht nur Spieler wie Reze und Cuisins gehalten, sondern sogar Spieler wie David Kofnatski dazugewonnen. Ja, Abgänge wie Derry Scherhand oder Ibrahim Masar taten weh, auch John Jo Kenny, aber insgesamt war das auf dem Papier, wenn man das auch einfach mit dem Rest der Liga vergleicht, eine Mannschaft, wo du sagen musst, die muss und den Aufstieg mitspielen. Punkt aus Ende und das war auch das formulierte Saisonziel, da ist Stefan Leithel quasi vorangeschritten und hat das formuliert. Und dann dieser Auftritt auf Schalke, der alles ins Rollen bringt, der desaströs ist und der nicht erkennen lässt, was in diesem Sommer überhaupt getan wurde. Und so zog es sich durch. Ja, man hatte zwei okaye, maximal okaye Auftritte gegen den KSC und gegen Darmstadt. Und dann dieses fast schon Freakspiel, muss man mal sagen, der positive Betriebsunfall gegen Hannover, wo plötzlich Dinge geklickt haben und Hannover selber ja, wo man aber auch sagen musste, keiner hat hochgejubelt, denn dieses 3-0 ist ja auch, sag es Kevin.
In der ersten Halbzeit ja eigentlich zwei Tore machen können, also dann oder müssen, eins auf jeden Fall. Und Hertha hat mit dem 1-0 in Hannover dann quasi, da hat es wirklich Klick gemacht. Und ab dem Moment hat Hannover echt Probleme gehabt, überhaupt noch mal ins Spiel zu finden. Das war so ein Moment, wo das Potenzial aufgeblitzt ist bei der Hertha, weswegen ich sie auch vor der Saison deutlich, deutlich weiter oben gesehen habe. Aber für mich war damals schon, habe ich gezögert, weil Stefan Leitel ist für mich offenbar, hat in Hannover auch schon sehr gestruggelt. Er macht bisher den entscheidenden Schritt mit seinen Teams nicht, nämlich was du gesagt hast, dann, wenn man die Zeit hat, zu gucken, dass man in ein paar Wochen, Monaten wieder den nächsten Schritt macht. Das irgendwie geht es bei ihm ab. Aber ganz großer Punkt, und dann kannst du weiter in dein Monolog machen. Matthias hat das vorhin gesagt, Wohlfühlatmosphäre hat für mich das Gefühl, aber nicht nur, dass es diese Sorte in Berlin bei der Hertha nicht gibt. Das fing an mit den Dadai-Klans und keine Ahnung was, also ohne das jetzt abwertend zu meinen. Aber es war immer Unruhe drin, so wie das auf Schalke in Hamburg auch hattest. Ganz komische Gemengel. Ich kann das gar nicht so richtig beschreiben. Du kannst das viel besser wahrscheinlich fassen, weil du das miterlebst, aber auch von außen gesehen. Es hat Hertha für mich das größte Problem, dass Unruhe-Faktoren da sind im Verein, von außen rein vielleicht auch in der Mannschaft, auch bestimmte Spieler bevorteilt werden. Du hast mit Reze natürlich auch einen star Spieler, einen potenziellen Starspieler, was immer gefährlich ist in so einer Konstellation, wo du den Druck hast, dass alle funktionieren müssen und sich nicht nur auf einen verlassen. Das sind so ganz viele Faktoren, die dann dieses Potenzial vielleicht auch wieder einfach runterdrücken und erdrücken.
So.
Es folgt der Satz, den ich auch schon beim VfL Bochum gesagt habe. Es ist das Ergebnis jahrelanger schlechter Arbeit. Da müssen wir jetzt, klar, wir kennen jetzt gefühlt den Urschleimanfang und Winters und so weiter, aber wenn man sich allein die letzten Jahre anguckt, hat man den Schritt verpasst in der neuen sportlichen Gemengelage mit Geschäftsführung und Sportdirektor Benny Weber, sondern also überall muss eine sportliche Identität stecken und die hat Hertha in den letzten zweieinhalb Jahren nicht entwickelt. Wie möchte Hertha Fußball spielen und wie wählt man danach Trainer und Spieler aus? Das ist nicht passiert. Es wurde von der Berliner Weg ausgerufen, der auch löblich ist und der ja auch viel mit Nachwuchsförderung zu tun hat. Aber wie will man Fußball spielen? Das hat man verpasst und dadurch, also wenn man sich die Trainer anguckt, so Paldardai, Christian Fjeld und Stefan Leithelt, die haben in ihrem Spielansatz nichts miteinander zu tun. Und auch die einzelnen Spieler, du kannst einzelne Spieler rausnehmen und sagen, der gibt ja für sich ja Sinn, das ist eigentlich ein guter Spieler. Aber passt ein Michael Karbovnik als technisch beschlagnener Ballbesitzspieler zu einem Paldardai? Denn in dem Jahr wurde er ja geholt. Nein, passt er nicht. Also ist er links liegen gelassen worden und ist in ein Loch gefallen, aus dem er nie rausgekommen ist. Hat man Christian Fjeld die Zeit gegeben, als junger Trainer, der noch nicht viel Erfahrung im Profibereich hat, erst mal zu wachsen, ohne direkt um den Aufstieg mitspielen zu müssen und demnach einen Kader aufzustellen, der sofort funktionieren müsste? Nee, hat man nicht. Und Christian Fjeld hat schnell Ergebnistruck gespürt und ist von seiner Spielweise irgendwann abgesprungen und man hat nicht mehr erkannt, was da überhaupt auf dem Feld passiert. Stefan Leitel ist ein Trainer, der seine Lieblinge hat. Und das kann denn wie in Fürth funktionieren? Aber wenn du ihm das nicht gibst oder in dem Fall sogar sagst, Stefan Leitel hat sich auf die Dreierkette festgelegt und wir brauchen Schienenspieler, aber man holt keine Schienenspieler, sondern den x-zentralen Mittelfeldspieler, dann braucht man sich auch da nicht, wenn dann die Dinge nicht funktionieren. Also will sagen, es fehlt eine grundsätzliche sportliche Identität, nach der man einen Trainer auswählt und nach dem man dann die Spieler auswählt. Und dadurch passen diese Versatzstücke seit Jahren nicht zusammen. Das verunsichert die Mannschaft immens. Man hat einfach das Gefühl, dass das Team ums Team in den letzten Jahren an Kompetenz verloren hat. Es wurden jetzt wichtige und richtige Schritte vom Präsidium, was ja auch noch nicht lange im Amt ist gegangen. Man hat mit Ralf Huschen, Kevin du kennst ihn bestens aus Paderborn, einen sehr fähigen Geschäftsführer für die Finanzen geholt, der bislang einen sehr guten Eindruck bei Hertha BSC macht in seinem Jahr, dass er jetzt da ist. Und man hat zuletzt mit Dr. Peter Görlich einen neuen Geschäftsführer für unter anderem den sportlichen Bereich geholt, der aber auch Marketing und ähnliches verantworten soll, der sechs Jahre lang sehr gute Arbeit bei Hoffenheim gemacht hat. Das waren die Jahre mit Nagelsmann und Co., wo man Champions League gespielt hat, wo viele gute Entscheidungen getroffen wurden, wo man in Teilen– man muss Hoffenheim und das Projekt und Konstrukt nicht mögen– aber in gewissen Teilen war Hoffenheim regelrecht Marktführer, was Sportwissenschaft angeht, medizinischer Bereich, NLZ und so weiter. Also man hat jetzt fähige Leute, die natürlich aber auf der Geschäftsführungsebene immer eher langfristig wirken, die selten ad hoc etwas entscheiden können, wie der Trainer, was sofort einen Effekt hat und die sich das auch erst mal angucken müssen. Besonders Görlich, der erst seit dem 1. September effektiv im Amt ist. Aber auf ihn werden jetzt, glaube ich, harte Entscheidungen zukommen, weil sie unausweichlich sind. Du merkst, dass Trainer und Mannschaft nicht zusammenfinden. In den Entscheidungen von Stefan Leitel ist wenig Leistungsprinzip und Gespür für die Situation, um Spielsituationen zu merken. Du merkst, dass Benny Weber, ein Satz noch, dass Benny Weber ihm den Rücken stärkt, weil du jetzt auch spürst, dass Benny Weber in den letzten Jahren so viel an Kredit verloren hat, trotz seiner aufopferungsvollen Arbeit und den schwierigen Voraussetzungen, dass man weiß, dass wenn Stefan Leitel geht, wird Benny Weber auch gehen müssen. Deswegen tut Benny Weber einen Teufel und stellt selber die Trainerfrage, sondern bügelt das überhaupt nicht souverän medial ab. Und dementsprechend ist dieses gesamte Umfeld bei RTWC und auch die Verantwortlichen selbst, alles ist gerade panisch. Und deswegen entwickelt sich auch keine Konstanz, und dann fällt vielleicht mal so ein Sieg wie gegen Hannover runter. Aber eine langfristige Entwicklung sehe ich in dieser Konstellation nicht mehr.
Ja, Stefan Leitel verliert sich schon in Plattitüden. Wenn ich mir die Pressekonferenz nach dem Spiel jetzt anschaue, ist es für mich und klar, jetzt kann man sagen, was soll er auch sonst sagen. Es ist so dieses typische so, ich kann der Mannschaft keinen Vorwurf machen, finde ich immer. Wenn der Satz kommt, in so einer Tabellensituation weiß ich immer, okay, eigentlich kannst du dich jetzt auch verabschieden. Weil, also ganz ehrlich, die Leistung, du hast ja auch sehr aufgeregt über die Leistung auch zurecht. Das war wirklich krass. Als hätte ich niemals der Härte, ich habe ja vor dem Spiel auch gesagt, dass ich durchaus ein attraktives Spiel erwarte. Weil zwei Teams auf dem Platz sind, die vom Potenzial her offensiv Fußball spielen können. Und das ist halt krass, dass die Härte das gar nicht zeigt.
Weil sie das gefühlt nicht an die Hand bekommen. Stefan Leitel hat bislang, und das ist ja auch der größte Vorwurf aus Hannover, also in Fürth hat er irgendwie den Fürther, genau, in Fürth hat das irgendwie funktioniert, weil da vielleicht die perfekte Mischung seiner Spielertypen da war. Aber in Hannover hat man fehlende spielerische Entwicklung gesehen. Da war Hertha ein reines Umschalt-Team. Und bei Hertha, muss man so sagen, und der Fußball hat gereicht, als Hertha gegen den Abstieg gespielt hat. Da hat es gereicht, Fabian Reese mal tief zu schicken, und der macht die Kugel rein. Jetzt aber wird's so aufsteigen, die anderen Teams wissen das, und du musst jetzt eine Idee mit Ball entwickeln. Und wenn du dann aber weiter mit einer Dreierkette spielst, nicht funktionierenden Flügelspielern, einem Fabian Reese, der im Mittelsturm verhungert, jetzt zuletzt wurde die Viererkette geändert, aber auch einem Toni Leisner in der Abwehr immer wieder das Vertrauen gibt. Der soll den Spielaufbau orchestrieren. Bei allem Respekt vor Toni Leisner. Das geht nicht. Das geht nicht. Und stattdessen werden eher junge Spieler unter den Bus geworfen, was wiederum auch nicht zur Philosophie bei Hertha passt. Und du merkst einfach, es passt nichts ineinander. Und es sind nicht mal diese berühmten Ansätze da, die sich Verantwortliche oft klammern. Die Spiele sehen katastrophal aus. Also fast jedes Spiel in dieser Saison sah aus wie ein letztes Spiel unter einem Trailer.
Sie laufen einem Wunschdenken hinterher einfach. Das ist das Problem. Sie erkennen offenbar nicht oder sie gestehen sich nicht ein, dass sie momentan diesen attraktiven Fußball des favorisierten– ich sag's mal– Ligakrösus vielleicht, ist ja vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so, aber schon jemanden Verein, der mehr Geld hat, dass sie dem nicht gerecht werden können. Und dann kriegen sie es nicht hin, was jetzt zum Beispiel gerade unter Lieberknecht geschieht. Defensiv zumindest, sie nur mal zu rocken und dann halt ein anderes Spiel zu spielen. Das wieder, wie du gesagt hast, zu versuchen, außer Defensive heraus, eine Rese zu schicken.
Weil der Kader aber auch so nicht zusammengestellt ist. Das ist das große Problem. Der Kader ist für offensiven, dominanteren Ballbesitzfußball geplant. Du brauchst mit dem Mika El Cuisans, auch wenn er sich in den letzten Jahren gewandelt hat, er läuft mehr, er kämpft mehr, brauchst du jetzt nicht kämpferischen Umschaltfußball spielen. Mit Kevin Sessa brauchst du das auch nicht machen. Die Spieler sind sichtlich verunsichert von dieser Spielweise. Und das ändert sich wenig. Plötzlich hat man sich die Hoffnung der Fans an den 16-jährigen Kenneth Eichhorn, der das sehr gut macht. Aber dass es überhaupt so weit kommen musste, zeigt ja, wie schlimm es um die eigentlichen Leistungsträger steht. Selbst Fabian Reese, der der oberste Schützling von Stefan Leitel ist, ist nicht wieder zu erkennen.
Hast du 2. Liga aber auch vielleicht nicht verstanden. Das ist keine Treterliga, so wie früher, aber es ist einfach– frag mal in Darmstadt nach– das ist einfach eine Grundvoraussetzung, dass das neben der tollen Stimmung einfach auch in Defensivverbund passt. Das ist jetzt abgedroschen, das klingt abgedroschen, aber die hat er kassiert einfach haarsträumende Gegentore auch. Das aus Spielsituationen heraus, wo das völlig gar keinen Not tut.
Du kannst aktuell jeden Aspekt nehmen.
Das kommt jetzt in die Situation gerade. Also wie haben die das jetzt hingekriegt in diesem Moment?
Durch völlige Verunsicherung.
Auf der anderen Seite kratzten Felix Götze vom… Ich weiß gar nicht, Kufnacki oder wer war es?
Kufnacki.
Kufnacki kratze es von der Linie. Das passiert auf der Gegenseite nicht, wenn der Elze Bilbia da kommt. Der 2. Minute kann Bilbia zwar auch schon das Tor machen, aber dann nachher… Den Spieler haben die in dem Spiel gar nicht im Griff und der war beim SC Kindesau unter dem Ding durchgelaufen. Außer Form, der macht hier zwei Tore und hat noch die Chance für ein drittes. Als wir letztes Heimspiel die Fans gefragt haben, wer war für die der Spieler spielt, haben drei Fans uns am Mikrofon gesagt, frag mal lieber nach dem schlechtesten Spieler des Spiels und auch der Saison bisher. Dann haben wir gesagt, wer ist das? Dann haben sie alle durch die Bank gesagt, Philipp Bilbia. Und der ist der Matchwinner in Berlin.
Und sagt nach dem Spiel, und wie viel Spiegel kannst du der Hertha vorhalten, sagen, ja Berlin als Stadt ist schon schön, aber Fußball spielen will ich hier nicht, ist mir alles ein bisschen zu unruhig. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Matthias, vielleicht noch deine Passenzen zu Hertha, und dann wiegen wir das Ganze mal ab.
Ja, also ihr habt jetzt schon die defensive Anfälligkeit erwähnt, aber wenn man sich jetzt inklusive des Pokals die sieben bisherigen Pflichtspiele anschaut und haben sie halt fünfmal auch gar kein Tor geschossen. Und das ist für einen selbsternannten Ausstiegskandidaten eigentlich ein vernichtendes Zeugnis. Ich fand es vor der Saison gut, dass eine Mannschaft sich da aus der Deckung wagt, aber offenbar war das Feld ja gar nicht dafür bereitet, also dass man sich da wirklich in der Rolle hätte sehen dürfen. Und ich finde auch, dass man der Hertha anmerkt, dass– also du hast alles schon gesagt im Endeffekt– mag aber, dass sie es überhaupt nicht verstehen, dem Spiel ihren Stempel aufzudrücken. Und das bedeutet ja nicht, dass man Ballbesitz wie blöd hat, sondern dass man auch mal versteht, ohne Ballbesitz das Spiel zu dominieren, in Anführungszeichen, oder zumindest im Griff zu haben. Und das fehlt der Hertha meines Erachtens absolut. Und wir hatten auch gerade den Namen Kenneth Eichhorn als The Next Big Thing schon mal fallen lassen. Ja, also auch für ihn alles andere als dankbar, in so einem Moment in dieser Mannschaft wirken zu dürfen oder zu müssen.
Weil man sagen muss, er macht das auch für seine 16 Jahre und sieben Wochen hart und beräumend gut. Also das muss man wirklich sagen.
Und den letzten Aspekt, den ich vielleicht noch ins Spiel bringen würde, auch hier hat Hertha ja gar nicht so viel Geld in die Hand genommen, um sich zu verstärken, aber man hat Geld in die Hand genommen, womöglich, um Rese und Cuisance zu binden. Und dann ist vielleicht die Frage, war das vielleicht der richtige Ansatz? Also man hat in bestehendes Personal investiert, was ja durchaus auch sinnig sein kann, weil man offenbar ja weiß, was die der Mannschaft geben können. Bei Neuzugänge ist das nicht immer gewährleistet. Aber zumindest schien mir das jetzt für den Moment nach dem sechsten Spieltag nicht der allerbeste Weg gewesen zu sein, dass ich hier viel Geld für diese beiden Personalien aufwende. Auf der anderen Seite aber kaum was investiere. Also ich hole einen Morris-Kratten-Macher, klar für eine gewisse Leihgebühr. Oder habt ihr den geliehen?
Nee, der war zum Nullbetrag geliehen, glaube ich.
Ja, okay. Aber es ist dennoch überschaubar. Also so unter das Bild ab.
Ich habe weiterhin krasse wirtschaftliche Zwänge. Das ist definitiv so. Und ja, du hast vollkommen recht. Es ist so, dass man einen Großteil des Budgets, quasi des Etats, dann an Reze und Cuisance, vor allen Dingen aber an Reze, gebunden hat. Und wenn dann aber quasi ein Großteil des Etats mit Cuisance und Reze auch nicht performt, weil du sie nicht in Rollen bekommst, in denen sie performen, naja, dann merkst du dann an anderen Stellen, dass da große Lücken sind. Wie gesagt, man hat mit Dreierkehrt die Saison gegangen, man hat keinen Schienenspieler verpflichtet. Die Schienenspieler sind Deo Seefolg als Rechtsfuß auf links und ein Julian Eitsperger, der tolles Talent ist, der eine gute Laie nach Essen in der Dritte Liga hatte, aber seine erste Zweitligasaison spielt. Und deswegen ist man jetzt auch abgerückt davon, spielt dann aber gegen Paderborn mit Dinos Gächter als Rechtsverteidiger. Das ist ein Experiment, was zur Halbzeit beendet wurde und was auch aussagt, Stefan Leith in dieser Kader, das fühlt sich bis heute fremd an. In vielen. Du kannst ja tausend Personalien durchgehen, das wäre jetzt nicht zielführend, aber du merkst einfach, dass es knirscht, dass diese Mannschaft nicht weiß, was sie auf dem Feld zu tun hat, in wenigen Spielsituationen, dass es sie massiv verunsichert und dass natürlich unter Verunsicherung die individuelle Klasse irgendwann begraben wird.
Vielleicht tue ich ihm auch jetzt Unrecht, aber für mich ist– und ich bin gar kein Fan von Trainerentlassungen– aber das ist für mich das perfekte Beispiel bei Stefan Leithel gerade, wo es meiner Ansicht nach absolut Sinn machen würde, darüber nachzudenken. Das können viele sagen, wenn die das nächste Spiel gewinnen. Ja, klar, siehst du.
Ja, bei dem Punkt ist man hinaus, denn selbst das Spiel gegen Hannover hat man ja 3-0 gewonnen und es hatte gar keinen Effekt auf die Mannschaft.
Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass das, wie du sagst, da passt es nicht einfach. Es passt nicht. Und ich will damit nicht sagen, dass Stefan Leitl das Große nicht kann. Also, das mit der Mannschaft zum Aufstieg zu führen. Also, eine Mannschaft mit Favoritenstellung, so müssen wir es besser formulieren. Es scheint einfach vom Umfeld nicht zu passen, vom Typ her nicht. Er ist natürlich auch ein Typ, so er wickt auf mich immer sehr ruhig und besonnen und…
Er hat teilweise neidisch über Teams wie Elbersberg geredet und immer wieder die Kotsmüge im Verein und die Ruhe angesprochen.
Ich sehe den nicht an der Seitenlinie rumtanzen. Also…
Wehe, also er coacht schon, aber…
Also, ich vergleiche jetzt, ich war wieder aus Palabona-Sicht mit Brüder auf, Baumgart, Quasniok Typen, die an der Seitenlinie mitpumpen, die das Team mit nach vorne peitschen. Ich glaube… Weiß ich nicht, ob ein Räser und Co. mit solchen Typen umgehen können, keine Ahnung, dafür kenne ich sie zu.
Man hatte auch da gefühlt jetzt alle Trainertypen durch.
Ja, gut, bei 4L finde ich es tatsächlich schade, dass man dem nicht mehr Zeit gegeben hat, da die anderen Trainertypen der letzten Jahre habe ich auch nicht so wirklich verstanden. Den schätze ich immer noch als ein großes Trainertalent ein. Ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen verbrannt durch die Nummer. Mal gucken, wo der nochmal unterkommt, aber weiß ich nicht. Für mich passt dieser Typus-Trainer nicht zu dem, was Hertha machen möchte. Wenn sie überhaupt genau wissen, was sie machen möchten. Das ist natürlich ein Punkt, den du noch viel besser gerade beschrieben hast. Da will ich glaube ich der eine das, der nächste das und dann wollen sie es unterschiedlich erreichen und das ist immer ganz, ganz, ganz schwer.
Hertha muss eine neue Kultur entwickeln. Da ist Peter Görlich jetzt an oberste Stelle gefragt. Und ich glaube, an dem Punkt können wir diesen Schwerpunkt Hertha dann auch zumachen und ich kann übergehen in das Outro. Denn wir haben diese Sendung jetzt geschafft, würde ich behaupten. Ich bin damit auch sehr zufrieden. Es hat großen Spaß gemacht. Ein, zwei Teams mussten wir so ein bisschen skippen, aber es ist nun mal so. Ansonsten Kevin, Matthias, vielen lieben Dank für eure Zeit. Es hat großen Spaß gemacht und ich hoffe, dass wir vielleicht ja sogar in der Konstellation uns irgendwann wieder haben. Ansonsten mit Eva, einzeln. Es wird toll. Bis dahin macht es gut. Und die Begrüße an alle HörerInnen. Unterstützt den Rasenfunk-Supporters-Club und schreibt gerne ins Forum, wie es euch gefallen hat. Ciao!
Danke, tschüss!
Ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.